Let me put it this way, Mr. Raymer. The 9000 series is the most reliable computer ever made. No 9000 computer has ever made a mistake or distorted information.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 51 am Mikrofon Tim Pritlove. Und was ich schon immer mal sagen wollte, Chaosradio Express ist ein Podcast vom Chaos Computer Club. Ich weiß nicht, wie häufig ich das schon nicht gesagt habe, aber schön, dass wir immer darüber gesprochen haben. Ach ja, by the way, es ist auch nicht der einzige Podcast vom Chaos Computer Club, sondern hier steht ja auch noch das Chaos Radio Podcast Network dahinter. Und wer nur Chaos Radio hört oder nur Chaos Radio Express hört, um genauer zu sein, der sollte sich vielleicht mal auch auf unseren Webseiten ein wenig umschauen. Da gibt es so illustre Kanäle wie zum Beispiel Chaos TV, was eine bunte Mischung aus allerlei Wahnsinn und vielleicht auch nützlichen Informationen ist. Da gibt es demnächst auch mal wieder ein paar ganz tolle Sachen. Hint, Hint. Oder das Dossier Chaotique, wo wir so unseren Pressespiegel zusammenfassen, wenn über den Club oder mit dem Club berichtet wird, in der sogenannten Presse, dann kann man das dort wiederfinden, also in der AV-Presse, sage ich mal, gemeinhin auch als Fernsehen bezeichnet. Aber das soll jetzt alles nicht das Thema sein heute, sondern das Thema ist Anonymität im Internet. Anonym sein, warum und wie und dafür ist heute Andreas Lehner dabei. Hallo Andreas.
Hallo Tim.
Du bist auch beim Chaos Computer Club auch schon eine ganze Weile. Wie lange eigentlich schon?
So über zehn Jahre.
Über zehn Jahre, das ist ja meist so schlecht. Und du bist einer der Initiatoren eines oder mehrerer Anonymizer, schwieriges Wort, Anonymizer-Projekte. Darüber wollen wir jetzt reden. Wir befinden uns gerade so am Vorabend der zweiten großen Demo gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Und deswegen, also nicht nur deswegen, aber auch deswegen ist das natürlich jetzt auch ein Thema. Das wollen wir aber sprechen wollen. Aus der Perspektive heraus, wozu braucht man das? Warum sollte man das vielleicht für sich erwägen? Sich also anonym durch die Netze zu bewegen? Und vor allem, wie macht man das? Ja, das war mal ein Einstieg. Warum eigentlich? Also, es gibt ja dieses schöne geflügelte Wort, ich habe ja eh nichts zu verbergen, ich kann mich ja auch irgendwie nackt auf meinem Fenster-Sim sitzen und den Puller raushalten. Wen stört das schon?
Es gibt diesen großartigen Comic, 1993, im Internet weiß niemand, dass du ein Hund bist, das mag damals gegolten haben, heute weiß man nicht nur, was für ein Hund du bist, sondern auch, dass du ein Hund bist, auf welche Rüben du so stehst, was du gerne frisst und was du in deiner Freizeit machst und welche Bäume du markierst.
Und wer dein Halter ist, wie viel Steuern er dafür zahlt.
Oder auch nicht.
Oder auch nicht, genau. Aber auch wenn er nicht zahlt, wo der Halter wohnt, wie alt er ist, seine Freundin und so weiter.
Genau.
Warum?
Weil Telekommunikation, insbesondere digitale Kommunikation, überwachbar ist und weil sie überwacht wird. Du hattest das Stichwort Vorratsdatenspeicherung angesprochen und die morgige Demonstration dagegen. Wogegen da demonstriert wird, ist die grundsätzliche und allumfassende Speicherung von Metadaten von Kommunikation. Bis dato wurden da eher Inhalte abgegriffen. Man denke an die klassische Telefonüberwachung. Da ging jemand mit zwei Krokoklemmen in die Vermittlungsstelle im Ort, hat sich da aufgeschaltet und konnte der Kommunikation zuhören, wenn gegen jemanden Verdacht vorlag. Das war ein relativ hoher personeller Aufwand. Man musste da tatsächlich hingehen. Und das hatte entsprechende auch rechtliche Sicherungen abgeleitet aus dem Grundgesetz, aus dem Fernmeldegeheimnis. Danach dürfen Einschränkungen nur durch ein Gesetz angeordnet werden. Dann gibt es einen Richtervorbehalt, dann gab es Katalogstraftaten. Und nur wenn in solchen besonders schweren Fällen das vorlag, dann konnte jemand und durfte jemand abhören. Technisch konnte das natürlich auch sonst. Allerdings gab es auch organisatorische Schutzmaßnahmen auf dieser Ebene. Zum Beispiel, weil das Telefonnetz in Europa zunächst und eigentlich auch überall sonst auf der Welt von staatlichen Akteuren betrieben wurde. Und die Leute, die in der Vermittlungsstelle saßen, waren Beamte. Und die haben entsprechend den Rechtsweg befolgt, der ihnen vorgegeben war. Das ist bei privaten Akteuren die Frage, ob die nicht aus Marktinteresse heraus im Zweifel auch laxer mit Sicherheit umgehen, denn die kostet einfach Geld. Das hat sich offenbar als erfolgreiches Instrument für die Strafverfolgungsbehörden dargestellt. So ist auch die Zahl der Telekommunikations-Bewachungsmaßnahmen im Bereich klassische Telefonüberwachung massiv angestiegen. Was auch daran liegt, dass die Digitalisierung es ja viel billiger gemacht hat.
Was gibt es da für Zahlen?
Da gibt es recht wenige Zahlen. Auch die Benachrichtigungen funktionieren offen gestanden nicht wirklich, wenn man das so liest. Es gibt Christoph Gusi von der Universität Bielefeld. Der hat irgendwann mal ein Gutachten gemacht über tatsächlich Telefonüberwachung in Deutschland, Ausweitung dieser Maßnahmen, wofür diese Instrumente gebraucht werden. Was in der Sache liegen mag, ist, dass natürlich die Strafverfolgungsbehörden darüber ungern sprechen.
Aber gibt es denn eine Berichtspflicht?
Es gibt eine Berichtspflicht.
Und wie sieht die aus? Also wer muss da wen, was?
Die Staatsanwaltschaft benachrichtigt den Betroffenen nach Abschluss der Maßnahme.
Den Betroffenen. Das heißt, wenn man selber eigentlich abgehört wird, dann müsste man danach so einen Brief bekommen mit sehr geehrter Bürger.
Sie wurden vom 17. Januar bis zum 14. März des Jahres 2005 abgehört, weil da ein Verdacht wegen Verstoß gegen dies und jenes Gesetz gegen sie vorlag. Die Maßnahme wurde beendet.
Und diese Zahl dieser versendeten Briefe, das ist sozusagen die entscheidende Größe?
Genau.
Und weißt du da irgendwie eine Zahl?
Nicht.
Okay. Aber es sind immer mehr geworden.
Aber es sind immer mehr geworden. Die veröffentlichen sie auch. Es gab auch, es gibt ja parlamentarische Kontrolle darüber. Nicht ausreichend offenbar, aber es gibt parlamentarische Kontrolle. Und dort werden natürlich auch die entsprechenden Fallzahlen behandelt, um zu gucken, hat sich dieses Gesetz bewährt. Hilft es tatsächlich, das erreichte Ziel umzusetzen? Ist es verhältnismäßig? Und durch die technische Vereinfachung wird es halt einfach sehr viel stärker angewandt. Ich nehme an, du hast mit Tobias schon mal einen Podcast gemacht. Wenn nicht, solltest du es tun.
Über digitale Telefonie.
Genau.
Über Telefonsysteme haben wir gesprochen.
Ab 1997, wenn ich mich recht entsinne, ist die letzte deutsche Vermittlungsstelle digitalisiert worden. Und damit gab es natürlich auch die beliebige Fernabfragbarkeit von Anschlüssen über die berechtigten Stellen, die sogenannten Bedarfsträger. Das heißt, das Bundeskriminalamt musste nicht mehr in eine beliebige Teilnehmervermittlungsstelle auf Ortsebene fahren, sondern konnte…
Was ist denn ein Bedarfsträger?
Ein Bedarfsträger ist ein Strafverfolgungsorgan oder eine andere Sicherheitsbehörde des Bundes oder der Länder, der Bedarf daran hat, deine Telekommunikation abzuhören.
Also es ist Ihnen ein Bedürfnis? Ah, und das heißt schon mit der Digitalisierung im Zuge der Einführung dann auch von ISDN. Also ISDN ist ja sozusagen nur die letzte Meile, aber vorher wurden ja auch schon alle Vermittlungsstellen digital. Damit war auch schon die Überwachungsschaltung möglich?
Damit war, soweit ich weiß, die zentrale Fernabwrackbarkeit möglich.
Das heißt, jede Vermittlungsstelle musste so eine Maschine einbauen, dass man auf Knopfdruck an irgendeine Verbindung rankam?
Ich weiß nicht, wie sie das technisch umgesetzt haben. Da bin ich überfragt. Da müsste man noch mal möglicherweise mit Leuten sprechen, die sich mit EWSD oder dem Alkartel-System auskennen. EWSD ist das elektronische Wählsystem digital von Siemens. Alkartel hat ein konkurrierendes System. Die damalige Bundespost und heutige Deutsche Telekom hat schlauerweise nicht nur sich auf einen Hersteller verlassen, sondern zwei Systeme eingesetzt, sodass wenn ein System nicht mehr funktioniert, nur die Hälfte des Netzes wegsammelt. Aber es gibt über die technische Umsetzung kaum Berichte. Es gab 1997, 1998, nehmen wir an, das war im Rahmen des deutschen Herbstes, 20 Jahre deutscher Herbst 1997, einen Bericht über die Fernabfragbarkeit bzw. es gab einen allgemeinen Bericht über Terrorismusbekämpfung, wo das BKA ganz kurz die Fernabfragbarkeit erläutert hat und auch entsprechend ihre Maschinen gezeigt hat.
Okay, aber jetzt ist das alles schon eine Weile her, also das Telefonnetz ist digital und mittlerweile läuft ja auch die Kommunikation nicht mehr primär über das Telefonnetz. Die Zeiten sind jetzt, also weiß der Geier, wo primär kommuniziert wird, aber es ist natürlich klar, dass jetzt auch sehr viel im Internet kommuniziert wird und auch auf ganz andere Art und Weise kommuniziert wird. Gewisser Hinsicht sogar schon fast noch sehr viel vertraulicher, weil Leute natürlich auch Dokumente, Dateien, Fotos, was nicht alles darüber schicken, was sie natürlich vorher mit dem Telefon mit wenigen Ausnahmen nicht gemacht haben. Wie sieht denn die Überwachungssituation ganz konkret da heute aus?
Nun, es gab zunächst eine Harmonisierung in den Vereinigten Staaten und dann eine Harmonisierung der Überwachungsschnittstellen auf europäischer Ebene im Telefonnetz. Das war auch immer noch begrenzt auf Sprachkommunikation, nicht auf Daten.
Harmonisierung heißt technische Standardisierung.
Das lief in den Vereinigten Staaten unter dem Begriff Kalea und hier unter Infopol. Da hat auch Erich Möchel relativ viel dazu geschrieben. Da ging es darum, dass das Europäische Telekommunikationsstandardisierungsinstitut Etsy Standards vorgeschrieben hat, wie Abhörschaltungen zu erfolgen haben. Auch im Hinblick auf eine mögliche europäische Vereinheitlichung, grenzüberschreitende Strafverfolgung, sei es durch Europol, weiß nicht, was da die Zielsetzungen tatsächlich waren. Da war die Argumentation, es wird billiger und einfacher, wenn diese Schnittstellen harmonisiert sind. Und damit gab es ein System, das europaweit ermöglichen soll, fernabfragbare Überwachungsmaßnahmen zu schalten.
Das sollte es geben, oder das gibt es jetzt?
Na, es gibt...
Oder es gibt nur die technischen Voraussetzungen dafür?
Es gibt die Technik und es gibt die technischen Voraussetzungen, wie weit das in der Bundesrepublik eingesetzt wird. Das entzieht sich meiner Kenntnis. Da sprechen die Strafverfolgungsbehörden auch nicht gerne drüber.
Aber weiß man denn, an welcher Stelle es ansetzt? Weil ich meine, das Internet ist ja nun kein so zentralistisch verwaltetes System wie jetzt das Festnetz der Telekom. Sondern da gibt es hunderttausende Internet-Service-Provider. So viele sind es nicht, aber es sind auf jeden Fall eine dreistädige Zahl von Internet-Service-Providern, die jetzt Zugang zum Internet anbieten. Jetzt mal für Deutschland oder deutschsprachigen Raum gesprochen. Haben die dann alle irgendwelche Zugänge?
Na zunächst, soweit ich das verstanden hatte, war es möglich, nachdem sich früher sehr viele Leute über ISDN eingewählt hatten, nicht nur die Sprachkommunikation abzugreifen, sondern auch bei ISDN Einwahl dann die Datenkommunikation, weil letztlich das Telefonnetz der einzige Zugang zum Internet war, weil es kaum andere Leitungen gab außer Standardfestverbindungen und ISDN Einwahl für den Gemeinden Bürger. Darüber ließ sich also diese Kommunikation abgreifen. Und damit war auch erstmalig Daten tatsächlich da. Faxkommunikation lief ja auch über Telefonleitungen. Und dann hat sich erstmalig eben IP-Kommunikation, aber eben vermittelt über ISDN in der Regel abgespielt. Das heißt, da wurden die Kommunikationsinhalte und auch die Metadaten abgegriffen an der jeweiligen Vermittlungsstelle bei der letzten Meile zum Nutzer. Was halt auch möglich ist, ob der Struktur des Telefonwennens ist. Du hast ja richtig bemerkt, dass das im Internet nicht mehr der Fall ist. Weswegen es mutmaßlich dann auch, also zunächst gab es auf jeden Fall in den Core-Routern Zugänge. Es gibt Techniken, die es erlauben, einfach in den Core-Routern auch hochbandbreitige Leitungen abzugreifen. Es gibt Technologien, die Glasfaser splitten. Da steckst du einmal Glasfaser rein und zweimal kommt es raus.
Also mit Core-Router meinst du jetzt so die dicken Maschinen bei jedem Internet-Service-Probeier?
Bei den ISPs und möglicherweise auch bei den Netzknoten. Es gab diese Geschichte Tapping Room Nordkoscher. Die Holländer waren uns relativ weit voraus mit dieser Technik. Am SIX gab es tatsächlich einen Switch der Bedarfsträger des Inlandsgeheimdienstes.
Was heißt Tapping Room Nordkoscher?
Das war ein Artikel, der besagt hat, dass die eingekaufte Abhörtechnik nicht nur den eigentlichen Zweck erfüllt, der beworben wird, sondern auch noch einen weiteren Zweck hat. Dass also nicht nur die staatlichen niederländischen Bedarfsträger Zugang zu der Kommunikation am holländischen Internetknoten am SIX haben, sondern auch möglicherweise dritte über eine großzügig dimensierte Wartungsschnittstelle.
Wer soll denn das dann sein?
Das sind Sachzusammenhangsvermutungen oder Verschwörungstheorien. Aber mutmaßlich der Hersteller oder die jeweiligen Regierungen des Landes, in denen der Hersteller seinen Sitz hat. Das war vor kurzem auch zu sehen, als die Firma 3Com an Huawei verkauft wurde, dass sich plötzlich die Regierung der Vereinigten Staaten Gedanken gemacht hat, ob sie nun plötzlich chinesische Backdoors in ihren Switches haben.
Okay, also wir wollten ja eigentlich über Anonymität reden. Aber ich merke jetzt gerade selber, es ist vielleicht erstmal ganz wichtig zu verstehen, was eigentlich das technische Bedrohungspotenzial ist, die man sich gegenüber ausgesetzt hat. Weil ich denke halt auch, dass viele Leute doch eine sehr, simpel will ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber doch eine sehr romantische Sichtweise auf die Funktionsweise des Netzes haben und wie sie sich dort bewegen. Man klappt irgendwie seinen Rechner auf, dann klickt man irgendwie so eine Webseite an, die spuckt irgendwie sofort die Daten an. Man hat immer das Gefühl, der Webserver, der mir eben jetzt diese Informationen gibt, der liegt irgendwie direkt hinter meinem Bildschirm. Und das ist ja nicht der Fall, sondern das geht dann erstmal durch meine Wohnung und dann geht es irgendwie in so einen Router. Und auch schon diese Maschine sieht alles.
Letztlich geht es zunächst in deinen Keller. Aus deinem Keller geht es auf irgendeinen D-Slam auf der Straße, also einen Verteilerkasten. Von dort geht es über eine Leitung in das Kernnetz. Von da geht es möglicherweise in ein weiteres Kernnetz über das Leitungsköpazitäten gemietet werden, falls dein Anbieter zum Beispiel nur stadtweit operiert. Von dahin geht es zu nationalen oder internationalen Austauschknoten wie besagten Amsics, dem DZX in Deutschland oder stadtweiten Austauschknoten.
Also da, wo mehrere Provider an demselben Ort angesiedelt sind, um sich eben Leichtdatenübergaben machen zu können.
Von dort geht es dann, wenn im Zweifel spiegelbildlich wieder nach unten, wenn also Kommunikation zwischen zwei Endnutzern stattfindet oder bei Inhalteanbietern wie Web-Servern geht es in irgendein Rechenzentrum. Und alle Beteiligten auf diesem Weg können Kenntnis von der Kommunikation nehmen, weil das Netz digital ist, lässt sich das auch relativ leicht filtern, im Gegensatz zum analogen Telefonnetz. Damals lässt sich jetzt in Zeiten, insbesondere paketvermittelter Kommunikation, aussieben, was du gerne sehen möchtest. Was die Handhabbarkeit natürlich deutlich erleichtert, das war ja auch früher nicht möglich, die gesamte Telekommunikation zu speichern. Das ist es auch heute nicht. Das sind einfach zu große Mengen, um das wegzuschreiben. Am DZX-Gene meines Wissens gerade 50 Gbit die Sekunde durch, das kriegst du auf keine Platte weggeschrieben.
Aber das ist ja auch genau der Punkt. Bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung geht es ja erst mal gar nicht so sehr darum. Der Name ist ein bisschen verwirrend, weil man irgendwie das Gefühl hat, alle Daten werden jetzt gespeichert. Aber es geht ja gar nicht so sehr um die Daten, die man überträgt. Vielleicht im Ausnahmsfalle auch, das weiß ich gar nicht genau, aber primär geht es ja um die Verbindungsdaten. Und da denken sich ja viele Leute auch immer wieder so, naja, na gut, jetzt hab ich mir halt irgendwie apple.com eine halbe Stunde angeschaut. Daraus wird man mir doch wohl keinen Strick drehen können.
Das mag richtig sein, außer man kommt in so religiöse Fäden zwischen Unix, Windows und Macintosh-Nutzer. Vielleicht schon. Darüber hinaus ist es aber so, dass die Kommunikationsinhalte tatsächlich in der Regel nur bei konkreten Maßnahmen gespeichert werden. Also bei dem, was früher das Abhören war, dass also jemand entscheidet zu diesem Anschluss, also zu diesem Teilnehmer, dir letztlich die Kommunikationsinhalte speichern, mitlesen zu wollen, überprüfen zu wollen, abhören zu wollen. Das ist aber eine Einzelfallentscheidung, die vorgenommen werden muss, und das bindet Personalkapazitäten. Es kostet einfach Geld und Zeit, dazu zu hören, was quatschen denn die zwei Trottel den ganzen Tag am Telefon. Automatisiert auswertbar hingegen sind die Metadaten. Das beinhaltet also, von wem aus hat eine Kommunikation wohin stattgefunden, zu welchem Zeitpunkt, zu welcher Dauer. Im einfachsten Fall einen Telefonanruf von dir zu mir zu dieser Uhrzeit mit dieser Länge von Festnetz auf Festnetz. Findet dies in einem Mobilfunknetz statt, wird zusätzlich noch die Zelle bei Gesprächsbeginn gespeichert. Das heißt also der Standort des Nutzers zum Zeitpunkt der Annahme des Gesprächs. Und da kommen wir dann potenziell schon in den Bereich, wo man tatsächlich was zu verbergen hat. Sei es, wenn man sich unerlaubt aus der Schule fernhält, weil man gerade mal keine Lust hatte, da hinzugehen. Dann ist natürlich der Standort sehr wohl eine bedeutsame Sache, wenn ich rausfinde, dass du aber im Kaufhaus an der Ecke vor den Videospielen gestanden hast und eben nicht im Kunstunterricht zwei Stunden abgesessen hast.
Wobei ich glaube, Schulschwänzen steht jetzt nicht unbedingt so im Mittelpunkt, zumindest noch nicht im Mittelpunkt der Bedarfsträger. Tolles Wort. Ich meine, mit den Beispielen ist das immer so eine Sache. Ich höre immer eine Menge schlechte Beispiele. Aber was ich ganz überzeugend bedrohlich fand, das sind so Sachen wie medizinische Zusammenhänge. Ich meine, die Gesundheitskarte und alles, was da noch daran hängt, das reißt diese Häuser wahrscheinlich sowieso schon ein. Aber natürlich ist auch ein Gespräch mit einem Arzt, der Spezialist ist für ganz besondere Fälle. So, wo man eigentlich schon allein dadurch, dass man mit diesem Arzt überhaupt kommuniziert und dann vielleicht auch noch regelmäßig sich sehr gut ausrechnen kann, was hier wohl das Thema ist.
Gegenstand der Kommunikation ist Seien, Abtreibungskliniken.
Ja, auch so viele Auseinandersetzungen mit Urologen mögen wahrscheinlich auch schon Schlüsse nach sich ziehen lassen können. Also das sind, glaube ich, auch Sachen, wo man eben eine Privatsphäre hat, die man dann a. leicht verraten kann und b. die dann auch Konsequenzen haben kann im Beruf, weil man irgendwie bestimmte Voraussetzungen nicht mehr hat oder weil man schlimme Sachen gemacht hat, die man eben nicht tun soll, blablabla. Und die dann nicht unbedingt sofort auf irgendeiner Webseite stehen, aber die dann halt im Zweifelsfall in irgendwelchen Anklagen oder Untersuchungen, wo man auch vielleicht als Zeuge geladen wird oder mit Verdächtiger auf einmal ermittelt wird, weil man rein zufällig eben mit demselben Arzt, der auch den Terroristen, der letzte Woche wieder irgendwas hochgejagt hat oder angeblich irgendwie involviert war, zu tun hatte. Also das sind so Sachen, die mir als erstes einfallen. Gibt es noch andere Fälle, die du so nennen würdest an der Stelle?
Es ist jetzt die Frage, wie weit wir da schon tatsächlich sind. Bisher hatten wir nur übers Telefonnetz gesprochen. Da ist natürlich die Anzahl der Fälle noch möglicherweise überschaubarer. Jetzt ein kritischer Fall, und das ist tatsächlich auch endlich angekommen. Die sind aufgewacht, ein bisschen später, aber immerhin. Das sind die Journalistenverbände, die erkannt haben, dass kein Informantenschutz mehr vorhanden ist, wenn Kommunikationsvorgänge nachvollziehbar sind. Stimmt. Und das geht halt nicht nur um...
Wenn man jemanden bei einer Behörde anruft...
Es geht halt nicht nur um Fälle von Geheimnisverrat. Das war ja auch dieser Cicero-Fall, der relativ bekannt wurde, wo das BKA ermittelt hat. Nun kann ein Journalist keinen Geheimnisverrat begehen. Er ist ja nicht Geheimnisträger.
Cicero-Fall ist sicherlich jetzt nicht eben ein Begriff.
Kannst du das mal kurz... Es gab den Journalisten Bruno Schirrer, der eine Hausdurchsuchung durch das Bundeskriminalamt erlebt hat, weil er ein Dokument, lass mich mal ganz kurz nachgucken, worüber das ging... Das war ein Porträt über einen irakischen Terroristen, Abu Musab al-Sakawi. Bei dieser Gelegenheit hat er aus Akten des Bundeskriminalamtes zitiert. Da haben sich natürlich auch, möglicherweise auch deren Aufgabe, die Abteilung Innenrevision im Bundeskriminalamt gefragt, woher hat er denn eigentlich diese Dokumente. Und haben versucht, einen Abfluss von Geheimnissen nachzuvollziehen. Und bei dieser Gelegenheit hat er sein Haus durchsucht und sein komplettes Archiv beschlagnahmt.
Eines Journalisten.
Eines Journalisten. Und die Frage dahinter ist nun, wie weit ist es verhältnismäßig, um möglicherweise ein Leck in einer Behörde zu finden, in die Pressefreiheit einzugreifen und dessen gesamtes Archiv mitzunehmen, was ja einen Überblick erlaubt, was er die letzten 15 Jahre gemacht hat, mit welchen Themenfeldern er sich so beschäftigt hat. Und wenn er nicht sehr gründlich war, welche Quellen er möglicherweise dazu hat. Schließlich ist es sehr aufwendig, jedes Papier in einem Dokument zu analysieren und zu verschleiern.
Und das ist halt das, was jetzt quasi durch die, also erst mal sowieso schon durch Telefonüberwachung, die ja schon Praxis ist, gefährdet wird. Und natürlich auch durch diese besonders fortgesetzte, geplante Methode der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wo ja gar nicht mal dann jemand überwacht wird, wenn man der Meinung ist, man müsste den jetzt mal überwachen.
Sondern prophylaktisch.
Sondern wo einfach alle generell schon mal vorab überwacht werden für den Fall, dass man nachträglich da mal reinschauen müsste. Weil im Prinzip ist ja jeder verdächtig.
Genau. Das ist also eine Umkehren der bisherigen Annahme, dass man so lange unschuldig ist, bis man als schuldig bewiesen ist. Man wird zunächst mal unter Generalverdacht gestellt und möglicherweise entlasten einen ja die dabei entstehenden Daten. Im Gegensatz zu den bisher stattgefundenen Fällen ist es halt auch so, dass das nicht mehr solche Mengen an Personal bindet. Es kostet tatsächlich Zeit, Observationskommandos loszuschicken. Der Bundesnachrichtendienst hat sich recht deutlich blamiert, als er unter anderem Erich Schmidt-Innbom, ein Journalisten, der viel über den BND-Fälle von Korruption und Versagen dort aufgedeckt hat, einfach über Jahre hinweg überwacht hat mit einem beeindruckenden Personalstab, wo sich auch die Frage stellt, wer trägt eigentlich diese Kosten, was hat der Steuerzahler davon, dass hier ein Journalist gegängelt wird. Aber letztlich sind es immer noch Einzelfälle, die auch bekannt werden als Einzelfälle, weil es nur Einzelfälle sind, weil es aufwendig und teuer ist. Bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung habe ich Metadaten, die ich automatisiert rastern kann in Echtzeit. Und es ist nicht so, dass ich sagen muss, ich suche nach etwas bestimmten einer Person, sondern ich durchsuche alle Daten aller Menschen nach bestimmten Mustern. Und wenn dein Lebenswandel sich in die Nähe eines solchen Musters begibt, bist du nochmal einer intensiveren Kontrolle würdig. Und möglicherweise findet man, wenn man lang genug rumstochert, ja irgendwas. Und wenn es nur ein Anfangsverdacht wegen Mineralölsteuerhinterziehung ist.
Also mir fällt jetzt auch gerade noch ein anderes Beispiel ein. Ich habe vor kurzem von dem Vorgang im Lawblog gelesen von Udo Vetter, der so irgendwie aus seinem Alltag ja immer schöne Berichte, also aus seinem Rechtsanwaltsalltag immer schön berichtet, immer schön anonymisiert berichtet im Übrigen, immer sehr schön zu lesen, wie wenn Herr A und Frau B und so weiter, die so ein jenes Problem haben, wo es die Vetter immer schon klar macht, aber natürlich nicht verrät, wer jetzt dahinter steckt. Und eine der Sachen war, dass häufiger dann mal Staatsanwälte anrufen und sich erkundigen, wie denn ein Mandant von ihm zu erreichen sei. Woraufhin er ihm dann irgendwie erklärt, dass er jetzt schon in der Zwickmühle ist, weil allein schon diese Frage ihm sozusagen Kraft des Gesetzes, Paragraph Tralala, in die Lage versetzt, ihn zu verklagen, weil er im Prinzip schon einen Gesetzesbruch begeht, wenn er eben auch nur danach fragt. In dem Moment, wo allerdings die ganzen Verbindungsdaten, was du vorhin ja schon gesagt hast, ich rufe ihn auf seinem Handy an, und man weiß genau, wer, mit wem, wann und dann eben durch die Zweitauswertung der Handyzelleninformationen, wo, wie man ihn erreicht und wo man ihn erreicht, das fällt halt auch einfach an. Sodass halt im Zweifelsfall ein Staatsanwalt auch dann auch nur noch auf irgendeine Taste drückt und sagt, naja, also die Daten müssen ja sowieso schon irgendwo liegen, dann schauen wir doch da mal rein, weil wir brauchen das ja.
Sobald man Daten sammelt, wecken die Begehrlichkeiten, die sind da und die kann man in weitere Nutzungen zuführen. Und ja, du hast das Beispiel LawBlog angesprochen, der vielleicht kurz als Beispiel über das BKA, die hatten, das hat zumindest das LawBlog am 30. September berichtet, auf ihre Website über die militante Gruppe informiert. Das BKA hat Fandungsaufrufe, bittet um Hinweise aus der Bevölkerung zu bestimmten Straftätern, unter anderem jener militanten Gruppe. Und angeblich hat das BKA gespeichert, wer die Website zu dieser militanten Gruppe aufruft und diese unter einen Generalverdacht gestellt. Das heißt, jeder, der sich für diese militante Gruppe interessiert, ist zunächst mal verdächtig, er könnte ein Mitglied dieser militanten Gruppe sein. Das ist schon eine bemerkenswerte Logik.
Das machen wir nochmal ganz langsam aufrollen. Also, verdächtig waren Leute, die Fahndungsaufrufe auf der offiziellen Website des Bundeskriminalamtes angeschaut haben. Also, wo man ja vermuten würde, ich bin da relativ selten unterwegs, ich würde ja vermuten, dass da eigentlich eher so die treuherzigen Bürger, die hilft der Polizei und alles wird gut denken, dass die sich dort rumtreiben.
Staatsanwälte mutmaßlich, Juristen.
Sind das nicht die Leute, die immer der Meinung sind, dass sie nichts zu verbergen haben? Es ist aber witzig, oder? Im Prinzip ist es aber auch schon nicht zulässig gewesen mit dieser Auswertung der IP-Adressen, oder?
Das ist meiner. Ich bin kein Anwalt. Aber meiner Rechtsauffassung nach ist es nicht zulässig. Andererseits hat das BKA soweit ich weiß, zumindest zum damaligen Zeitpunkt, keine wirkliche Datenschutzrichtlinie veröffentlicht. Vielmehr veröffentlichen sie im Press und den Hinweis, dass das Downloaden und Spiegeln ihrer Webseite verboten sei. Das heißt, wenn ich es mir nicht downloaden kann, kann ich es mir nicht angucken. Da hat jemand das Internet nicht verstanden.
Also gerade das Speichern von IP-Adressen in Web-Server-Logs. Also vor ein paar Jahren gab es ja viele Diskussionen darum, dass der Apache-Web-Server die Open-Source-Software vom Big Brother Award auch einen Preis verliehen bekommen hat, eben genau dafür, dass eben wenn man die Software installiert by default die IP-Adressen mit den Log-Files reingeschrieben werden. Da gibt es natürlich viele Gründe dafür, blablabla, Länderauswertungen, Statistiken und so weiter. Und natürlich im Falle von Attacken will man natürlich auch wissen, wo die herkamen und so. Aber das ist im Prinzip genau das, wozu das führt. Also alle Websites heutzutage, man kann davon ausgehen, dass wahrscheinlich nahezu alle IP-Adressen einfach mitschreiben, ohne sich jetzt vielleicht groß was dabei zu denken. Da fallen Daten an. Und wie du schon gesagt hast, wenn Daten erst mal angefallen sind, dann wecken sie Begehrlichkeiten. Und auch wenn das bisher immer noch sehr hypothetisch klang, naja, wer will denn schon was mit den IP-Adressen von dieser Webseite, dann hat man irgendwie so ein Forum, dann schreiben da irgendwie ein paar verrückte Trendscrot-Träger, die zwei Tage später eine Schule niedermähen, ein paar komische Sachen und schon sind alle Leute, die dort sich eben auch noch mit rumgetummelt haben, potentiell irgendwie auch eine Zielgruppe. Das muss man schon bedenken. Also ich finde, der Freiheitsaspekt wird hier doch ganz sträflich missachtet. Jetzt sind wir ja mit diesen IP-Adressen schon so ein bisschen auch in diesen Punkt gekommen, wo eigentlich Anonymität endet im Internet. Also man fühlt sich ja immer so frei, man klickt da irgendwie so rum, keiner guckt zu, es ist dunkel, niemand geht mehr auf der Straße spazieren, die anderen schlafen alle und man surft.
Ist damit automatisch überwachbar?
Ist schon überwachbar, aber ich meine, was sind denn jetzt eigentlich die eigentlichen Sachen, mit denen man verfängt im Netz? Also ich meine, was man glaube ich kaum oder fast nicht, darüber werden wir glaube ich noch reden, fast nicht verhindern kann, ist ja, dass man bemerkt, dass man überhaupt irgendwie aktiv ist. Aber es fängt ja im Prinzip schon mit den Daten, die man hin und her schickt an. Da empfiehlt sich natürlich für Sensitives ohnehin mit Verschlüsselungen zu arbeiten oder bestimmte Daten einfach überhaupt gar nicht erst auf das Internet zu geben. Was sind denn noch so andere typische Datenspurfälle, die man dann vielleicht durch Anonymisierung verhindern kann?
Zunächst möchte ich noch mal kurz auf die Verschlüsselungen eingehen, weil die auch bei Anonymisierung natürlich ein bedeutsamer Bestandteil ist. Verschlüsselung schützt zunächst nur Kommunikationsinhalte. Das gewinnt ja schon mal ziemlich viel. Das erlaubt es eben, den tatsächlichen Kommunikationsinhalt zu sichern. Bei klassischer Telefonie wiederum, um dann noch mal zurückzukommen, ist es ja der Hauptbestandteil dessen, was da läuft. Da ist der Inhalt des Gesprächs das Wichtige. Und die Tatsache, dass eine Kommunikation stattgefunden hat, erscheint zunächst weniger bedeutsam. Das ist im Netz meiner Meinung nach was ganz anderes. Unter anderem, weil es natürlich erlaubt zu rekonstruieren, was du angeguckt hast. Wenn du nämlich über eine SSL gesicherte Website dir ein Bild lädst, dann ist dieses Bild zwar verschlüsselt, aber die tatsächliche Adresse ist halt weiterhin nachvollziehbar. Und wenn man das Gesamt zusammenführt, dann weiß ich ja weiterhin ungefähr, welchen Pfad hast du genommen, wofür hast du dich interessiert. Weswegen man eben auch die Metadaten verschleiern soll, kann und muss. Und das letztlich bietet ja auch dieses Anonymisierungssystem. Darüber hinaus kannst du natürlich auch über einen verschlüsselten Kanal, der zunächst mal Dritte von dieser Kommunikation ausschließt, also ist dir und deinem Gegenüber erlaubt, auf diesen Kommunikationsinhalt zuzugreifen und schützt dich vor Dritten. Die Metadaten sind weiterhin einsehbar. Das kannst du umgehen, indem du dir einen Stellvertreter suchst. Dann kommunizierst du also nicht direkt mit deiner Gegenstelle, sondern kommunizierst mit einem Stellvertreter. Im einfachsten Fall ein Webproxy. Da gab es früher anonymizer.com. Das ist ein Proxy, über den du surfst. Das heißt, im Log des Web-Servers, im Apache-Log, taucht dann nicht mehr deine Adresse auf, sondern die dieses Proxys.
Langsam, jetzt komme ich nämlich schon ein bisschen in die Techniken, aber ich wollte vorher noch mal ein bisschen darauf eingehen, was eigentlich jetzt so diese gefährdeten Sachen sind, die man... also wie bleibt man überhaupt hängen im Web? Wir hatten die IP-Adressen, so Cookies sind sicherlich auch ein Thema. Davon gibt es ja eine ganze Menge. Also wenn man im Web sich bewegt, fast jede Webseite heutzutage hinterlässt, diese kleinen Kekse. Was sind so deine Erfahrungen, was darüber nachvollziehbar ist?
Nun, mit einem Cookie, das ist eine eindeutige Kennung, die dir der Webserver zuweist, die dein Browser dann bei jedem Besuch dieser Webseite zurückgibt. Die haben eine bestimmte Gültigkeitsfrist, allerdings gehen sehr viele Webseiten dazu über diese Gültigkeitsfrist oder das Ende der Gültigkeitszeit auf 2038 zu setzen.
Quasi auf immer?
Ja, auf das Ende der UNIX-Systemzeit auf immer. Dann ist aber halt die nächsten 30 Jahre klar, was du da tust. Das ist schon ganz schön lange. Und das erlaubt es natürlich denen, nachzuvollziehen, selbst wenn du von einer anderen IP-Adresse kommst, selbst wenn du mit einem anderen Browser möglicherweise kommst und einen Cookie-Manager hast, so was gibt es ja wohl auch, nachzuvollziehen, dass du immer noch du bist.
Und man kriegt das ja auch nicht nur von den Webseiten, in die man geht, sondern man kriegt auch auch Cookies reingelegt von der Werbung, die dort geschaltet wird. Also entweder ganz konkret von den Firmen, die dort werben, oder von solchen Werbeplattformen, die natürlich auch ganz gerne Nutzungsdaten erfassen wollen und dafür auch alle diese Cookies verwenden. Also in seltensten Fällen ist ein Cookie wirklich für das eigene Anliegen wirklich wichtig.
Das erlaubt einem eine gewisse Bequemlichkeit, wenn du beispielsweise den Nutzernamen von Wikis speichert. Das erleichtert es dir, wenn es ein Wiki ist, bei dem du dich anmelden musst, um etwas zu editieren, dass du dich nicht jedes Mal anmelden musst. Die Frage ist halt, ob das bisschen Bequemlichkeit nicht sehr hoher Preis ist für...
Also die Standard-Einstellung ist halt bei den allermeisten Browsern so.
Bequemlichkeit, ne?
Cookie kommt, super abspeichern, kein Problem. Und bei jedem Klick werden alle diese Cookies, die von dieser Webseite gesetzt worden sind, immer wieder mit übertragen, solange sie halt noch gültig sind. Dann hattest du noch Reforger genannt vorhin.
Genau, wenn ich auf eine Webseite komme, dann überträgt in der Regel der Browser den Hinweis, wie ich auf diese Seite gekommen bin, also woher ich komme. So dass beispielsweise, das kann man natürlich auch nutzen, um sein Angebot zu optimieren, eine Webseite sieht, ich komme von einer Suchmaschine mit der Anfrage, Bücher online kaufen jetzt, schnelle Lieferungen versandkostenfrei, und kann damit sagen, dann wollen wir dieses Aktionsangebot, ohne Versandkosten Bücher zu versenden, einfach dauerhaft fortführen, weil es uns Leute bringt. Das erlaubt aber auch, derjenigen Website Rückschlüsse zu ziehen, nach dem, was ich gesucht habe, bei der Suchmaschine vorher.
Das heißt, wenn ich da Pornos, Schlampen, kleine Kinder eingegeben habe und ich komme auf die Website, dann ist diese Information auch dabei?
Das ist ja bisweilen auch ganz lustig. Ich saß mal mit jemandem aus dem Club zusammen, der einen Webblog betreibt und da tatsächlich Referrer speichert und auch IP-Adressen speichert, was ich grundsätzlich nicht so toll finde. Und ich habe ihn gebeten, zu gucken, ob eine Adresse da aufgetaucht wäre. Und er meinte, die wäre da aufgetaucht. Und die Suchstring war kalte Fusion zu Hause. Da haben wir uns auch beömmelt, was deutsche Beamte in ihrer Freizeit so machen. Letztlich sind es aber halt Informationen, die es erlauben. Wenn ich beispielsweise von meiner Homebanking-Website auf irgendwas anderes gehe, dann sehe ich als Betreiber dieser Website, dass derjenige gerade von dieser und dieser Bank kommt, dann kann ich ihm möglicherweise zielgerichtet Fishing-Attacken unterspielen, etc. Es sind einfach persönliche Daten, die ich damit preisgebe, weil man Browser sie automatisiert, ohne das Wissen des Betroffenen herausgibt.
Man kann sich damit auch ganz gut verraten, auch wenn man so eigene Bookmark-Seiten hat, ein eigenes Wiki, was vielleicht offen erreichbar ist, aber was nirgendswo verlinkt ist, von dem keiner was weiß. Und man klickt dann seine eigenen Links an auf eine andere Webseite, dann wird im Prinzip die Adresse bei dem Server, wo es hingeht, gleich abgelegt.
Google nutzt es, um Seiten, die sie noch nicht im Cache zu haben, zu spydern. Beispielsweise, weswegen es eine schlechte Idee ist, Inhalte in Netzen vorzuhalten, ohne Authentifizierung, sondern nur durch das Geheimhalten der Adresse. Denn wenn dann ein Mitarbeiter mal auf Google klickt, selbst wenn er nicht einen Link klickt, sondern einfach als nächstes auf Google surft, dann kriegen die den Referrer und spydern das, was auch dazu geführt hat, dass sehr viele interne Dokumente der amerikanischen Behörden am Anfang in Google zu finden waren im Cash. Das war schon ganz praktisch.
Okay, was wird denn noch so übertragen? Also mit jedem Klick geht ja sowieso auch noch eine ganze Menge andere Informationen über das eigene Betriebssystem und so.
Ach so, ja gut, der Browser-String wird übertragen, das Betriebssystem. Das mag ganz hilfreich sein, solange das Browser gibt, die nicht das komplette Feature-Set verstehen, dann ist es sicherlich für den Betreiber hilfreich zu wissen, dass es sich hierbei um ein Mobiltelefon handelt und der dem jetzt bitte nicht die großen Grafiken zuwirft.
Aber man weiß halt auch, hier ist ein Mobiltelefon unterwegs.
Mit dieser Software-Version. Genau, hat das letzte Mal ein Firmware-Update gemacht. Da und da. Und das erlaubt auch, Exploits zu steuern, weil ich natürlich darüber zwar nicht unbedingt preisgebe, wer ich bin, aber ich gebe preis, was für eine Software betreibe ich. Und damit kann ich gezielt Software angreifen, ob der Schwachstellen, die für diese und diese Version bekannt sind. Wenn ich weiß, es handelt sich hier um einen Microsoft Internet Explorer 4, dann kann ich halt dann PNG hinschicken und weiß, der explodiert gleich.
Sehr hilfreich für den Bundestrojaner.
Zum Beispiel ist ja auch die Frage, wie die in den Rechner kommen werden. Da ist auch noch, da kommen wir wieder zur Anonymität. Bei dem Bundestrojaner die Frage oder bei der Remote Forensics Software, wie sie das nennen, wobei Forensics so ein bisschen vorgaukelt, dass keine Manipulation auf der Maschine möglich wäre, was es natürlich ist. Wenn ich erstmal die Kontrolle über eine fremde Maschine habe, dann kann ich natürlich auch dort Beweismittel fälschen oder gar ablegen, deren Argumentation vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht…
So wie das klassische Kokain-Päckchen bei der Hausdurchsuchung.
feingelassen wird in den Spielfilmen in Hollywood, genau.
Was haben Sie denn hier, Herr X?
Nun ist die Frage, ob man tatsächlich den Strafverfolgungsbehörden des Bundes unterstellen möchte, dass sie Beweismittel fälschen. Deren Argumentation ist noch dazu, dass sie ja keine Beweismittelsicherung damit vornehmen wollen, sondern lediglich einen Anfangsverdacht feststellen wollen. Dann stellt sich allerdings die Frage, warum das BKA das als Fahndungsinstrument möchte und nicht nur der Verfassungsschutz, der als Vorfeldermittlungsbehörde da ist. Auf der anderen Seite scheinen ja auch gerade die aus den Erfahrungen des Nationalsozialismus sehr sinnvollen Trennungen zwischen Polizei und Geheimdiensten, die zwar nicht explizit im Grundgesetz qualifiziert sind, aber daraus abgeleitet werden, auch durch das Bundesverfassungsgericht, abgeleitet wurden, warum die zunehmend aufgehoben werden und warum sich da insbesondere Herr Schäuble zur Aufgabe gesetzt hat, die Sicherheitsbehörden des Bundes stärker zu vernetzen.
Der fand das nicht so schlimm irgendwie. Er meinte, die müssten ja auch mal zusammenarbeiten und es kann ja wohl nicht sein, dass irgendwie die Arbeit der Bundesbehörden eingeschränkt werden.
Der hat auch kürzlich auf der Herbsttagung des Bundesnachrichtendienstes sich dazu hinreißen lassen zu sagen, es könne ja nicht sein, dass die Arbeit des Bundesnachrichtendienstes durch parlamentarische Kontrolle eingeschränkt werden würde. Da bin ich mir nicht sicher, wie ich das zu interpretieren habe. Heißt das lediglich, die Parlamentarier müssen einfach einen Vollzugriff in Kopie haben, damit sie die Mitarbeiter nicht stören? Oder heißt das vielleicht, sie wollen keine Kontrolle haben? Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Es ist etwas unklar, was dort gewünscht wird. Und das alles ist ja auch das, was einfach dieses große Misstrauen auch derzeit lostritt. Also das ist das, was ich so bemerke. Nach vielen Jahren einer etwas nachlässigen Vorgehensweise wird jetzt bei vielen Leuten schon so eine gewisse Sensibilität erzeugt. Das hat man auch schon gemerkt bei der ersten Demo gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung hier in Berlin. Da war ja echt eine Menge los. Also ich selbst habe das vollkommen unterschätzt. Ich dachte mir so, na, wenn da ein paar hundert Leute kommen und so, da können sich die Nerds feiern lassen. Am Ende waren es, na ja, je nachdem, welchen Zahlen man so glaubt, aber so an die 10.000 Leute werden es schon gewesen sein. Das ist schon eine Menge, vor allem für so ein abstraktes Thema. Man merkt jetzt auch wieder, wir wollen jetzt über Anonymität im Internet reden. Das ist so schwer, mit den Händen zu greifen, indem man einfach erst mal versucht, was ist denn die Ausgangslage? Und dann so, na ja, Cookies, IP-Adressen, geht's noch? Jetzt kommen schon wieder diese Computerspinner und picken irgendwelche Rosinen aus dem Fleisch und wollen mich daran erinnern, dass ich auf meinen Pornseiten surfe. Aber darum geht es ja nicht. Es ist einfach generell so, wir leben in einer Zeit der digitalen Kommunikationswege und das Abhören und Mitnachvollziehen und vor allem auch das langfristige Speichern dieser ganzen Kommunikationsvorgänge ist mit Einschränkungen ein Klacks. Also im Vergleich zu früher ist es halt viel einfacher geworden und das, obwohl die schiere Summe der Kommunikationswege angestiegen ist, natürlich auch die Anzahl der effektiven Ausnutzung dieser Kommunikationswege. Aber Milliarden E-Mails, ebenfalls Milliarden Telefonanrufe und natürlich auch jetzt in zunehmendem Maße verschickte Dateien und Chat zum Beispiel. Also wenn ich mir auch anschaue, wie viele Leute sich dann auch auf eine sehr private Ebene herunterlassen, wenn sie irgendwie chatten. Das schafft jetzt einfach eine Flanke, die so vorher nie da war. Und das ist dann eben gepaart mit einer Angriffsmöglichkeit, mit einem Arsenal auf der Gegenseite, was jetzt auch noch durch diese neuen Gesetze untermauert wird, die das im Sturm nehmen können, sozusagen. Und sich auch danach anschicken, das zu tun. Das ist mein Eindruck. Würdest du den teilen?
Den kann ich nur teilen, vielleicht kann ich dabei noch mal einhaken. Einerseits bin ich, wir hatten danach den Termin am Bundesverfassungsgericht noch so ein Gespräch.
Was für ein Termin?
Es gab eine Verhandlung vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht am 10. Oktober.
2007. Du sollst vielleicht mal das Ja sagen. Es ist 2007.
Es ist der 5. November heute. Ja. Nee, der 6. Inzwischen.
Ich sollte eigentlich auch immer das Datum sagen, oder? Soll ich noch mal anfangen?
Nein.
Okay, also heute ist der 5. November 2007. Und ab sofort gibt es das jetzt immer bei Chaosradio Express dazu. Sag ich jetzt mal so, mal gucken. Vielleicht hab ich es beim nächsten Mal später vergessen.
Ich erinnere dich.
Ja. Und ich sag auch immer Chaos Computer Club. Ich bin schon froh, wenn ich meinen eigenen Namen rennt, der Krieger. Okay, also es gab einen Termin beim Verfassungsgericht.
Da war Gegenstand die Verhandlung über die Klage gegen das Nordrhein-Westfälische Verfassungsschutzgesetz, wo als erstes in Deutschland kodifiziert war, dass es die Online-Durchsuchung geben wird. Der Nordrhein-Westfälische Verfassungsschutz wollte für sich die Möglichkeit der Online-Durchsuchung, in diesem Fall eben auch nicht zur Beweisgewinnung, sondern zur Vorfeldermittlung. Deren Argumentation ist, dass durch Verschlüsselung, die zusehends eingesetzt wird, weil sie ob der extrem billigen Rechenleistung in Computern und der verfügbaren Bandbreite keinen Zugang mehr zu den Kommunikationsinhalten haben. Sie haben nur noch Zugang zu den Kommunikationsmetadaten. Das wird sich möglicherweise durch Anonymisierer ändern. Mal sehen.
Und das fanden sie so ein bisschen schade.
Also man hat schon das Gefühl, die sitzen jetzt eigentlich schon so vor den großen Internetbildschirmen und kriegen gerade alles mit. Und jetzt stellen sie fest, oh Gott, jetzt setzen sich die Leute, machen sie digitale Vermummung und jetzt wollen sie irgendwie, da sie ein Vermummungsverbot so richtig nicht durchkriegen, wollen sie einfach zu Hause gleich reinschauen.
Bevor du deine Kapuze aufsetzt, hinter dem Spiegel.
Im Schlafzimmer.
Bevor das Ding irgendwie aus dem Schrank gezogen ist. Super. Okay, was kam dabei raus bei dieser Anhörung?
Dabei kam raus, dass das Gesetz in der derzeitigen Form wohl nicht verfassungskonform sein wird. Da ist natürlich noch kein Urteil getroffen worden.
Aber die Richter waren sehr skeptisch.
Nun muss man dazu sagen, dass sich das Bundesverfassungsgericht grundsätzlich sehr zurückhaltend und sehr vorsichtig äußert. Beeindruckend fand ich die unglaubliche technische Kompetenz dort. Die haben sich einfach ungeheuer informiert. Die rechtliche Kompetenz ist sowieso gegeben, das Bestellungsverfahren ist ja auch relativ gut, da kommt nicht irgendjemand hin. Es ist auch eine Wiederwahl nicht zulässig, das heißt, man muss nicht irgendwie Gefälligkeitsurteile schreiben. Und so haben wir mit dem Bundesverfassungsgericht tatsächlich ein Instrument, das das Recht in Deutschland sichert und damit auch die Freiheitsrechte der Bürger. Und die Argumentation dort auch vor Gericht, das wurde auch mehrfach erwähnt, ist, dass es Freiräume geben muss, unbeobachtbare und unbeobachtete Freiräume für den Bürger, in denen die Bürger von ihren Freiheitsrechten Gebrauch machen können, wenn sie der Ansicht sind, dass diese Räume überwacht werden könnten. Selbst wenn sie es nicht faktisch sind, es ist ja auch bisweilen schwer festzustellen, ob eine Überwachungsmaßnahme, wenn nicht gar unmöglich, festzustellen, ob eine Überwachungsmaßnahme stattfindet, dann müssen sie dennoch der Ansicht sein, dass da keine Überwachung stattfindet, sonst machen sie von ihren Freiheitsrechten keinen Gebrauch mehr. Und das wäre fatal für die Bundesrepublik Deutschland und das in ihr befindliche System. Man kann ja über dieses Land viel Schlechtes sagen, aber die tatsächliche Architektur ist ja relativ gut, dass die Implementierung gerade ein bisschen schlechter ist. Na gut, da muss man mal debuggen. Aber letztlich funktioniert das ja ganz gut. Im Nachgang hatten wir dann noch mit ein paar Leuten gesprochen. Und deren Argumentation war, sie brauchen diesen Zugang, um Zugang zu den Kryptokies zu haben, damit sie zumindest für Einzelfälle die Verschlüsselung wieder aufheben können und feststellen können, was ist Inhalt der Kommunikation. Nun ist eben die Argumentation des klagenden ehemaligen Bundesinnenministers Gerhard Baum, dass es das nicht geben darf, dass es nicht verfassungskonform ist, weil es diese unbeobachtbaren Räume geben muss. Jetzt hat man auch wegen der mangelndemokratischen Kontrolle der Sicherheitsbehörden kaum Einblick, wie effizient, wie effektiv die sind, wie weit ihre Instrumente tatsächlich funktionieren, wie weit die angemessen sind. Insofern ist es auch schwierig, über Vorratsdatenspeicherung zu sprechen.
Weil es vielleicht nicht funktioniert?
Oder warum?
Ich glaube schon, dass sie funktioniert. Die Frage ist, ob sie notwendig ist. Es ist ein notwendiges und angemessenes und verhältnismäßiges Instrument. Wie hoch ist die Eingriffstiefe? Und die ist ja relativ hoch, wenn ich nachvollziehen kann, wo haben sich Leute in den sechsten Monaten aufgehalten? Und das kann ich automatisiert. Während es für Inhalte Personal braucht, kann ich Metadaten automatisiert auswerten. Es gibt unter anderem, über die Geschichte der Firma kannst du vermutlich mehr sagen, eine Firma, die irgendwie mal mit Apple zu tun hat, die Firma Harlequin. Die hatten mal irgendwie einen Dillon-Compiler geschrieben. Und darin eine sehr schicke Anwendung.
Du meinst, es war eine Lisp-geschriebene Software, die hieß Watson?
Die hieß Watson, genau. Xanalyst heißt die Firma inzwischen, weil sie das mal outgesourct haben. Deren Aufgabe ist es, Metadaten-Analyse zu machen. Die haben es damals insbesondere für den Bereich Business Intelligence, wie würde ich mich durch meine Logfiles, und eben auch für den Bereich der Strafverfolgung gemacht. Dass es letztlich darum geht, wie bekomme ich ein Interface, um mit den Rohdaten, die zu einem Fall vorliegen, Visualisierung zu machen, weil ich in diesen Logfiles nichts sehe.
Also kurz gesagt, das ist so eine Software, da gießt man einfach sechs Monaten Verbindungsdaten aller Bürger in der EU rein und dann am Ende kommt irgendwie genau eine Statistik raus, wo drin steht, wahrscheinlich hat diese Gruppe von Leuten mit dieser Gruppe von Leuten relativ viel zu tun und das sind so die Leute, die viel miteinander kommunizieren. Also man kann im Prinzip vollständige Beziehungsgeflechte, wer gehört zu wem, von Familien bis hin zu Firmen und natürlich auch der organisierten Kriminalität, sofern sie nicht, wie man das irgendwie meistens ja sieht, mit 25 verschiedenen Handys telefoniert und damit eben solche Geflechten sehr viel schneller entgeht als alle anderen. Das ist ja auch immer so eine Lehre, dass eigentlich der technische Ausrüstungsstand bei den Gruppen, die nun wirklich immer als Grund angesehen werden für solche Maßnahmen, so hoch ist, dass genau diese Maßnahmen dann eben gar nicht greifen. Also vielleicht nicht gar nicht greifen, aber zumindest...
Sehr eingeschränkt. In der Regel trifft es Fritzchen doof.
Genau. Und das ist natürlich das Problem, dass man immer diesen Querschläger hat. So, jetzt sind wir alle ganz beunruhigt. Und sehen langsam ein, dass man irgendwas tun muss. Da gibt es natürlich zwei Wege. Das eine ist sowas wie morgen. Demo bzw. überhaupt politischer Widerstand. Ein bisschen sich zu organisieren, um einfach gegen diesen Trend vorzugehen. Weil man kann jetzt auch nicht immer davon ausgehen, dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht am Ende schon wieder alles gerade biegen wird.
Das kann auch nicht sein, dass die ständiges Korrektiv für die Berliner Politik werden. Wenn die Große Koalition und auch Rot-Grün davor handwerklich schlechte Gesetze umsetzen und auch inhaltlich verfassungswidrige Gesetze bisweilen beschließen, dann kann es nicht sein, dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht stets korrektiv sein muss. Dann müssen die sich mal die Frage stellen, warum veröffentlichen wir die ganze Zeit schlechte Gesetze? Und beschließen die nichtsdestotrotz. Auch dank des Bundesverfassungsgerichts gibt es da dieses schöne... Ah, kurzer Einspruch. Du hattest in Chaosradio mal ein Lied gespielt von einer Gruppe namens Bundestag United. Da gab es Zitate verschiedener Politiker. Das ist eine großartige Nummer.
Das stimmt.
Und darin gibt es ein Zitat von Heribert Brandl, einem ehemaligen Gerichter und inzwischen Autor bei der Süddeutschen Zeitung, insbesondere für die Bereiche Inneres und Recht.
Kennst du denn alle Zitate?
Nicht alle.
Das müssen wir nämlich unbedingt mal rauskriegen. Das ist wirklich großartig. Ihr findet das übrigens bei ChaosTV. ChaosTV.TV 65 ist das. Der Sicherheitswahn. Meintest du das oder meintest du das andere?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, es gibt da zwei. Und in einem von den beiden sagt Heribert Brandl, Recht sichert Freiheit. Und...
Soweit ich weiß. Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich kenne ihn nur von Anhörungen und hab mit ihm nur ein, zwei Mal einen Satz gewechselt. Ich lese den sonst aber sehr gerne. Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass es seine Stimme ist. Und er sagt Recht sichert Freiheit. Und... Ja, darum geht's. Das Recht Freiheit sichert. Und das ist der Weg, den wir zum Beispiel vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht beschreiten, dass es rechtliche Einschränkungen der Überwachung des Bürgers gibt. Dass es Freiräume gibt, die dem Bürger erlauben, seine demokratischen Freiheitsrechte wahrzunehmen. Sich friedlich und ohne Waffen unter freiem Himmel zu versammeln. Und ich fand es, um nochmal diese Demonstration am 22. oder 23. September anzusprechen, ich fand es eine Unverschämtheit, nachdem im Vorfeld der Demonstration, soweit ich das vom AK-Fora mitbekommen habe, eine recht umfassende Sprechung mit der Polizei, die für die Sicherung dieser Demo eingesetzt wurde, stattgefunden hat, dass dieselbe Polizei dann bei einer Demonstration gegen Überwachung flächendeckend alle Teilnehmer fehlt. Das ist einfach eine Unverschämtheit. Und das ist nicht nur eine Unverschämtheit, das ist auch ungeschickt. Ich will nicht dumm sagen, aber es ist einfach ungeschickt. Das schafft schon ein Klima. Warum muss man das tun?
Ja, da hast du natürlich recht. Ich habe jetzt nochmal nachgeschaut. Es gibt ja diese zwei Bundestag-United-Dinger. Und worauf du dich beziehst, ist, dass mit dem Titel Kontrolle muss sein. Ich glaube, das spiele ich nachher nochmal einfach an. Aber bevor wir das tun, sollten wir jetzt auch nochmal den Bogen schlagen. Du hast schon gesagt, jetzt festgehalten, Recht sichert Freiheit. Aber allein das Recht scheint ja nicht auszureichen.
Oder zumindest ist es ja doch ein gewisses Misstrauen in einem Staat, der sich bisweilen nicht an seine Zusagen hält. Was mich auch in der letzten Zeit sehr im politischen Prozess beeindruckt, aber auch schockiert hat, ist, dass man uns als technischen Experten, als CCC zugehört hat, sei es im Fall von 202C Strafgesetzbuch, also dem Verbot von sogenannten Angriffswerkzeugen oder Hackathols, bei Wahlcomputern und all den Themen, die wir nun beackert haben in diesem Jahr, was auch ein recht spannendes Jahr war. Das aber nichtsdestotrotz von all dem, wo sie uns angehört haben und gesagt haben, wir sehen ihre Bedenken und eure Bedenken, nichts davon eingang in den tatsächlichen Gesetzestext gefunden hat, dass da keinerlei Schranken eingebaut wurden, dass keine Sicherungsmaßnahmen stattgefunden haben, dass man tatsächlich Leute angehört hat, genickt hat und gesagt hat, ja, das sind Bedenken, die sehen wir und sie komplett ignoriert hat. Und vor dem Hintergrund muss man sagen, da gibt es ein gewisses Misstrauen, ob denn tatsächlich augenblicklich die Art und Weise der Gesetzgebung noch funktioniert, ob die Sicherungsmaßnahmen noch greifen und ob sich das Problem wieder einschwingt. Das kann man natürlich sagen, das ist vor dieser Hysterie der Sicherheitsgesetzgebung durch die tatsächlich vermittelte, möglicherweise bestehende Bedrohung durch den Terrorismus. Ich kann das nicht so ganz einschätzen, wie real die uns tatsächlich bedroht, aber das ist auch ein schwieriges Feld. Dass aber vor dieser Hysterie tatsächlich auch handwerkliche Fehler gemacht wurden, dass Gesetze gepfuscht wurden und dass man mit dem Vertrauen des Bürgers spielt. Nicht nur die Parlamentarier, die Gesetze erlassen und in Anhörungen nicht mehr zuhören, sondern auch in so Dingen wie Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Online-Durchsuchung, dass man ein Klima schafft, wie auch auf dieser Demonstration. Dass man dem Bürger signalisiert, selbst wenn wir möglicherweise nicht in der Lage sind, diese technischen Maßnahmen so umzusetzen, dass wir dich kriegen, du musst davon ausgehen, dass wir es könnten. Denn die Online-Durchsuchung ist ja auch nicht dazu gedacht, um flächendeckend alle Computer zu erwachen. Aber du weißt nicht, ob dein Computer betroffen ist oder nicht. Und das schafft ein Klima. Und das schafft ein Klima der freiwilligen Selbstbeschränkung, wie das auch bei Videoüberwachung stattfindet. Das panoptische Gefängnis als Konzept sagt ja auch, wir brauchen weniger Wärter, weil die Menschen sich beobachtet fühlen. Ob sie es tatsächlich sind, entzieht sich ihrer Kenntnis. Aber allein dieses Gefühl der Überwachung führt dazu, dass sie ihr Verhalten proaktiv ändern, um einer Strafe zu entgehen. Dazu muss es natürlich Sanktionsmöglichkeiten geben, aber die sind ja nun da, die kann man auch qualifizieren. Und ja, dann bedeutet diese Überwachung, dass wir unser Verhalten ändern und unsere Freiheitsrechte nicht mehr ausüben. Und das möchte ich schlichtweg nicht. Und dann ist die Frage, wie kann man das sicherstellen, wenn Recht ein Weg ist, der aber nicht immer funktioniert, und dann ist Code der andere, dann schreibt man sich Software. Und das ist ja nur die Umsetzung der Rechte, die wir haben. Und wir qualifizieren diese Rechte, die wir haben, in Software, die es uns erlaubt, diese Rechte auch wahrzunehmen.
Ja, da hast du natürlich Recht. Bevor wir auf die Technik einspringen, was mir auch noch einfällt, gibt es immer diese schönen Interviews mit den Leuten, die immer nichts befürchten und so weiter. Und selbst wenn man denen dann aber auch so konkrete Bedenken vorträgt, so wie sie eben jetzt von uns hier diskutiert wurden, wie sie dann aber auch von den Journalisten auch hinterfragt werden, dann schauen die dann immer so ganz betroffen und denken sich so, na ja, das kann ja vielleicht sein, aber ich habe da das Vertrauen, dass da auch alles mit rechten Dingen zugeht. Dieses Vertrauen, da muss ich sagen, da kann man diese Leute eigentlich echt nur noch beneiden, weil mir das eigentlich schon längst abgeht. Und was macht die eigentlich so sicher, dass nun ausgerechnet in Deutschland, was es irgendwie geschafft hat, in einem Zeitraum von 50 Jahren zwei absolute totalitäre Überwachungsregime, Deluxe, zu installieren, in der DDR, in der Nazizeit, dass das alles so irreversibel ist, was wir derzeit an Freiheit haben. Dass eben nicht einfach Strukturen an die Macht kommen, die sich dann eben schön bedanken, über sowas wie Vorratsdatenspeicherung und sagen, oh ja, schön, dass ihr irgendwie uns die Instrumente geschaffen habt, um ein totalitäres Regime wunderbar mit dem Laptop zu kontrollieren.
Da möchte ich auch kurz einhaken. Einerseits hat Andi neulich ein sehr schönes Zitat gebracht. Ich war auf einer Konferenz in Hamburg, auf der auch Andi einen Vortrag gehalten hat. Und Andi hat in seinem Vortrag den bemerkenswerten Satz gesagt, als es um Lawful Interception ging, um Abwehrtechnik.
Also wir reden von Andi Malamagun.
Der hat in seinem Vortrag gesagt, der Unterschied zwischen dem demokratischen Rechtsstaat und einer totalitären Diktatur ist die Konfigurationsdatei im Fall von Lawful Interception. Und das wird den Leuten jetzt erst, wo diese Apparate existieren und schon da stehen, langsam erst klar. Denn die Technik ist dieselbe. Bei der Telefonüberwachung verkauft Siemens nun mal dieses eigene Lawful Interception Modul für die EWSD. Und ob das nun wie in der Bundesrepublik tatsächlich mit richterlicher Kontrolle geschieht, wo Menschen prüfen, liegt dort eine Straftat vor, die einem Katalog entspricht, der es erlaubt, diese Telefonifikation abzuhören. Oder ob wie beispielsweise im arabischen Markt ein Scheich sagt, ich bin der Staat, und Lawful Interception heißt, ich vertraue niemanden, also will ich alle abhören.
Das ist nur eine Konfigurationsdatei.
Die ist schnell ausgetauscht. Genau. Und dann ist halt die Frage, warum wollen wir diese Instrumente schaffen? Sind sie wirklich notwendig? Sind sie überhaupt geeignet?
Und sind sie das Risiko wert?
Sind sie das Risiko wert?
Also ist die Bedrohung, die man vielleicht unter Umständen abwehren kann, es wert, dass einfach alles komplett über den Haufen geht? Das verstehe ich auch nicht. Also dass das die Parlamentarier nicht schnallen.
Der eine Argumentation ist, so etwas wie der Nationalsozialismus wird nicht mehr passieren. Und das glaube ich Ihnen auch aufs Wort. Ich glaube aufs Wort, dass es dieses Vernichtungsregime nie wieder geben wird. Und jeglicher Vergleich damit zu sagen, hier entsteht das neue Rechtssicherheitshauptamt, den halte ich auch für vermessen. In dem Maße wird es nicht mehr passieren. Selbst dieser Stasi-2-0-Vergleich, obwohl er näher da ist und damit vielen Leuten auch präsent. Und das ist sicherlich eine gute Kampagne, um Leute aufzurütteln. Das ist nicht das Ministerium für Stadtsicherheit. Bei weitem nicht. Allein das Informationszuträgersystem, dieses Spitzel, wenn man das in Prozent der Bevölkerung ausdrückt, das gibt es hier einfach nicht. Wir sind eine freiheitliche Demokratie. Aber nichtsdestotrotz ist es...
Ja, man braucht es ja auch nicht mehr, dieses Zuträgersystem, weil man hat ja dann die Vorratsdatensprechung.
Was kann man mit diesem technischen Apparat machen? Und dann ist es nicht das Ministerium für Stadtsicherheit, sondern es ist irgendetwas Neues, eine völlig neue Qualität, die es erlaubt, ohne 200.000 Mitwisser ein Überwachungsregime aufzubauen, weil da reichen die 30 Techies, die da im Schichtbetrieb 24-7 unterm Flughafen sitzen.
Ja, an der Stelle finde ich den Vergleich Stasi 2.0 aber auch gar nicht so schlecht. Das ist dann einfach so, jetzt machen wir das mal in digital. Also es ist nicht vielleicht Stasi 2.0, aber es ist irgendwie Stasi digital. Stasi war ja wirklich erstaunlich analog. Mit ihren Geruchsproben, die sie irgendwie genommen haben und ihren riesigen Registerkarteien und Akten und was nicht alles. Und was mussten sie da nicht alles verbrennen, als sie irgendwie kurz davor standen, irgendwie komplett ausradiert zu werden. So, das geht jetzt alles irgendwie digital. Das lässt sich irgendwie leichter verschleiern und verschieben und kopieren und natürlich auch viel leichter anwenden. Insbesondere, wenn man es mit einer Kommunikationssphäre zu tun hat, die selber komplett digital ist. Wie praktisch. Also ich finde das schon noch ein... Ich würde es auch nicht so benutzen wollen, dass man jetzt den aktuell Regierenden unterstellt, naja, ihr wollt ja jetzt DDR neu machen. Aber ihr müsst euch schon vorwerfen lassen, dass ihr technische Einrichtungen schafft, über die sich die Stasi damals einfach...
Alle 10 Finger einzeln geleckt hätte.
Aber wirklich noch mit Kusshand. Also besser wäre es nun echt nicht gegangen.
Hätten die das gehabt, dann wäre das Regime vielleicht nicht untergegangen. Man weiß es nicht, die waren halt pleite.
Dann hätten sie mehr gewusst und mehr verhindern können. Also man kann natürlich auch Mutmaßen, ob da nicht wiederum offene Netze und so weiter. Aber darum geht es ja auch nicht. Es geht einfach darum, dass dann eben auch einfach dieses Bedrohungspotenzial da ist. Und jetzt sitzen wir hier, wir wissen nicht, wie es missbraucht wird. Und dieser Missbrauch findet ja auch statt. Gab es nicht sogar auch schon, da gab es noch neulich so einen Fall?
Da gab es so einen Fall, den fand ich sehr hübsch. Insbesondere, weil dann die Zuständigen im Sicherheitsapparat der Bundesrepublik gesagt haben, wir können und dürfen uns diese Diskussion jetzt nicht leisten.
Was war denn dieser Fall?
Dieser Fall war ein Mitarbeiter, soweit ich weiß, des Bundesnachrichtendienstes, des Deutschen Auslandsgeheimdienstes. Dessen Befugnis her strecken sich auf die Kommunikation im Ausland und mit dem Ausland. Nicht aber über Kommunikation im Inland. Die deutschen Botschaften, nein, die auf dem Territorium der Bundesrepublik befindlichen Botschaften fremder Staaten im Rahmen der Fernmeldeüberwachung kontrollieren, um darüber Erkenntnisse zu gewinnen. Die Theorie ist, wir hören einfach mal alle Botschaften ab. Und vielleicht erzählen die was am Telefon. Dazu muss es also ein Instrumentarium geben, das es erlaubt, Fernmeldeverbindungen zu überwachen. Das gibt es, diesen technischen Apparaten, die haben darauf natürlich Zugriff. Das ist ja auch ihr Job. Da kann man sich die Frage stellen, ob der BND ein zeitgemäßes Instrument ist, ob er ein geeignetes Instrument ist, ob er sein Geld wert ist, ob die parlamentarische Kontrolle funktioniert. Wir hatten ja diesen Untersuchungsausschuss auch wegen der Observationskommandos gegenüber.
Und wir haben einen Innenminister, der eine Frage stellt, ob das überhaupt noch stattgemäß ist, solche Ausschüsse zu haben.
Und dieser Mitarbeiter hatte wohl das Problem, das mag an seinem beruflichen Stress liegen, das weiß ich nicht. Das Problem, das wir bei den Sicherheitsbehörden ja auch immer haben, ist, dass es da immer weniger qualifiziertes Personal gibt. Die sparen ja auch massiv Leute ein. Ich habe lieber einen Polizisten auf dem Bahnsteig als eine Videokamera, weil mit dem kann man reden. Und wenn mich irgendwie die Nazis verprügeln wollen in Brandenburg auf dem Bahnsteig nach zum Vier, dann habe ich es gern, wenn da jemand steht, der großgewachsen ist und stabil und irgendwie eine Dienstwaffe hat, dann sagt, geh mal weg. Also wenn eine Kamera zuguckt, wie ich blutend auf dem Gleis liege, da kann ich nichts von kaufen.
Da kommst du auf YouTube.
Jedenfalls hat dieser Mitarbeiter ein Problem gehabt in seiner Ehe. Seine Frau hatte eine Affäre. Und er hat das dienstlich vorhandene Instrumentarium genutzt, um mal diesen Liebhaber auszuspionieren. Weil wenn das schon da ist, ist ja praktisch. Dann kann man mal gucken, was die da so macht und warum die es da tonen. Das weckt halt Begehrlichkeiten.
Genau, die Sache mit diesen Begehrlichkeiten. Das ist nämlich auch noch so ein Ding. Und vor allem gerade bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, was ich ja auch wirklich hanebüchen finde, ist, diese ganzen Daten, also wenn es mal der Staat wäre, der sozusagen diese Daten erhebt, dann irgendwo, naja, dann würde ich mich ja noch so halbwegs wohlfühlen. Aber nee, eigentlich auch nicht. Aber was ich noch schlimmer finde, ist, es ist ja auch gar nicht so, dass der Staat das erhebt, sondern er zwingt die privaten Unternehmen, quasi auf eigene Kosten für ihn zu arbeiten und dort die Daten erstmal zu hinterlegen, sodass sie irgendwie nur dann abgeholt werden, wenn sie auch wirklich gebraucht werden.
So ist das doch, oder?
Oder sehe ich das falsch, oder werden sie immer übertragen?
Also die Idee ist, dass diejenigen, die Telekommunikation anbieten für Geschäfts- und Privatkunden, Schnittstellen bereitstellen für die Agenturen für Staatssicherheit, wie es in den NC-Spezifikationen tatsächlich heißt. Also die reden schon von Staatssicherheit und nicht von Strafverfolgung.
Ach wirklich? Aha, naja, okay, wir haben nichts gesagt.
Und die Aufgabe ist es also, diese Schnittstellen bereitzustellen, damit diese abgefragt werden können. Die werden sie auf eigene Kosten bereitstellen müssen, die Anbieter von Telekommunikation. Das heißt, letztlich zahlt der Kunde für seine Überwachung, weil natürlich das Unternehmen, das marktwirtschaftlich operiert, diese Kunden umlegen muss, auf die Kosten für die Dienstleistungen, die sie erbringt. Klar, also zahlt der Bürger für seine eigene Überwachung einen Obolus. Und zwar für eine flächendeckende Vollzeitüberwachung, weil das muss die Schnittstelle hergeben. Dabei ist es allerdings so, dass es eine Vorgabe gibt, die sagt, dass wieder der Betroffene von dieser Maßnahme Kenntnis nehmen darf. Das ist nachvollziehbar. Wenn man Mitglieder der organisierten Kriminalität hat, will man nicht, dass denen doch ein Knacken in der Leitung kommuniziert wird. Wir hören dich übrigens ab. Das ist auch kein Problem mehr, das ist voll digital. Man kopiert halt irgendwie noch mal ein paar Bits weiter.
Da knackt gar nichts mehr.
Sondern es ist auch so, dass diese Anbieter von Telekommunikationsdienstleistungen strafbewehrt keine Kenntnis von dieser Erwachungsmaßnahme mehr nehmen dürfen. Während es früher so war, dass bei der Deutschen Bundespost tatsächlich da speziell ausgebildete Mitarbeiter zuständig waren für Abhörschaltungen, die die Legitimität dieser Schaltung geprüft haben. Die lasen, hat es einen Richter unterzeichnet, ist es einer dieser Katalogstraftaten, ist es noch an dem Zeitfenster, ist es gültig. Haben sie einen Formfehler gemacht? Und wenn es so war, dann gaben sie es weiter. Dann ging ein Techniker mit einem Akroko-Klemmen und einem Kassettenrekorder in die Vermittlungsstelle und hat die Teilnehmeranschlussleitung gesucht. Heute ist es so, dass in einer Behörde ein Mitarbeiter auf seinem Arbeitsplatz in seiner Applikation einen Doppelklick macht und dann hat er ein Audiofeed. Und davon darf der Betreiber der Telekommunikationsanlage keine Kenntnis nehmen.
Das heißt, es wird Equipment installiert, die einfach jederzeit einen Direktzugriff erlauben?
Ja, und da gibt es einen kompletten Feed durch.
Und davon erfährt der Internet-Service-Provider selber gar nichts. Aber es werden keine Daten, ich meine diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung, speichert ja auf Vorrat. Heißt das, dass dann live alle diese Daten in Echtzeit an eine Zentrale übermittelt werden?
Da bin ich überfragt, ob die vor Ort vorgehalten wird. Bisher war immer davon auszugehen, dass diese Daten vor Ort tatsächlich vorgehalten werden müssen. Auch der Bandbreite wegen. Die Gerüchteküche besagt, dass die Mitarbeiter der Sicherheitsbehörden nicht über ausreichende technische Kapazitäten verfügen, um auch jetzt schon geschaltete Maßnahmen erfolgreich auszuwerten, weil sie einfach die Bandbreite nicht haben und die Rechnerkapazität.
Auch wenn man nicht alle Daten mitschneidet, also auch die ganzen Verbindungen, die halt sonst gar nicht gespeichert werden, weil was soll das?
Ist schon ganz schön viel.
Ist einfach eine Menge Holz und das muss auch erstmal weggeschrieben werden. Und vor allem, das muss auch stimmen. Also wir wissen alle, was bei einer normalen Kommunikation alles schon schiefgehen kann. Aber dann auch noch etwas unter Umständen sogar gerichtlich, nachweislich, sozusagen als Beweis angeführt ist, noch Verwertbares zu erhalten, heißt ja auch, dass dieser ganze Prozess fehlerfrei laufen muss. Und niemand kann überprüfen, ob der auch fehlerfrei gelaufen ist.
Darf auch niemand überprüfen.
Da tochen auf einmal irgendwelche Bits auf, und die sagen hier, der Herr Lehner, das ist ja ein ganz fieser Schurke, ja. Also der hat ja hier mit nahezu allen Top-Terroristen telefoniert, die wir so kennen. Und dann bist du in der Beweispflicht, oder?
Gut ist die Frage, wie sich das um...
Hast aber auf jeden Fall erstmal ein Problem am Arsch, und das ist schnell mit einem Texteditor hergestellt.
Ja, oder weil ein Bit kippt im Speicher in der Maschine, die das auswertet.
Das soll ja auch mal passieren. Es ist so ein bisschen wieder wie bei Brasil, in jeder Hinsicht.
Tuttlebuttel.
Die Tuttlebuttel-Konfusion, die Fliege fliegt rein. Und auch so, was du vorhin schon gesagt hast, auch dieses, ja, das war bestimmt wieder Simmons. Der wollte sowieso, dass die Leute mehr für ihre Verhöre bezahlen müssen. Das wird jetzt irgendwie alles wahr. Ach Gott. Na gut. Schauen wir mal, bevor wir weiter nur noch hier klagen, schauen wir doch mal, was man jetzt auch dagegen tun kann.
Kommen wir also nochmal zurück zu den Vorratsdaten und der Bedeutung. Die haben wir. Wir haben also Geräte, die Vorratsdaten speichern. Das tun sie bisher im Telefonnetz. Das werden sie in Zukunft auch für jede E-Mail tun. Das werden sie für jede SMS tun. Das werden sie für jede Webseite tun, die abgerufen wird, damit man das auch sechs Monate im Nachhinein abfragen kann. Das ist die Frist, die jetzt vorgeschlagen ist. Es ging immer zwischen sechs und 24 Monaten. Interessanterweise haben ausgerechnet die Polen, wo man meinen möchte, die hätten aus ihrer Geschichte gelernt und sich die Vergangenheit über die Staatssicherheit angeguckt, diskutiert, das für 15 Jahre zu speichern. Das ist schon ganz schön lang.
Fünf, zehn Jahre.
Ja, war ihnen dann wohl der Speicherplatz zu teuer. Aber die Begehrlichkeiten sind offensichtlich da, von der Wiege bis zur Bare. Diesmal keine Formulare, sondern das lückenlose Kommunikations-Lockfall. Ich weiß auch nicht, was da der positive Ausblick ist. Im Club ist ja auch das noch kurz als Einschub immer die Diskussion, wo gehen wir gerade hin, was ist unsere Diskussion. Und alles, was wir tun, ist ja auf eine Art auch rückwärtsgewandt und bremsend in Bezug auf die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Wir versuchen halt Prozesse zu verlangsamen, die Kommunikation zur Erwachung herstellen. Was aber der positive Ausblick ist, das weiß ich nicht. Insofern, meiner ist es dafür sicherzustellen, dass diese Daten einfach nicht anfallen. Und sie werden ja nicht gebraucht. Und das ist ja auch immer die Argumentation, bei Flatrates heben die Anbieter diese Daten nicht auf. Warum? Auch die brauchen sie für die Abrechnung nicht. Das ist eh pauschal bezahlt. Das kostet nur Geld, die blöden Logs aufzuheben. Wer wann welche IP hatte? Meine Güte! Warum? Wofür? So, die brauchen die nicht. Und die Vorratsdatenspeicherung zwingen sie dazu, das aufzuheben. Und dann muss man sicherstellen, dass die einfach nicht anfallen. Und das ist die Lösung von Stellvertretern, die Anonymität herstellen. Anonymität heißt halt, eben keine Muster zu hinterlassen, eben nicht spezifisch verkettbar zu sein, meine Person mit den dort angefallenen Daten.
Ja, das ist jetzt erstmal gar nicht so einfach, weil man ja im Internet auf jeden Fall schon mal eine Adresse hat. Und wenn man jetzt anonym kommunizieren will, muss man aktiv irgendwas tun. Also es geht gar nicht mal nur so ums Weglassen, sondern man muss schon irgendwie verhindern, dass das, was sowieso anfällt, nicht anfällt.
Oder nicht auswertbar ist.
Wollen wir da mal einsteigen? Was gibt es denn da so für Methoden?
Das ist die Frage, gegen was man sich schützen möchte. Möchte man sich gegenüber seinem Kommunikationspartner schützen? Für die Beispiele der Cookies beispielsweise und der Referrer. Dann gibt es transparente Proxies, die man auf seinem Rechner installiert. Beispielsweise Privoxy, gibt es auch noch andere, die bestimmte Zeilen einfach löschen. Die sind ja ohnehin nicht betriebserheblich. Für die Durchführung eines erfolgreichen Abrufs einer Webseite ist es nicht notwendig, dass diese Webseite weiß, woher ich komme.
Das heißt, Privoxy ist eine Software, die installiert man sich auf seinem Rechner. Und dann surft man da so durch. Aber es ist auch im Wesentlichen jetzt nur für Web. Da geht es jetzt eigentlich nur um Webseiten. Wenn man also Bedenken hat, die neuesten Informationen des BKA zu konsumieren und dafür nicht gleich in irgendeinen Kerker geschmissen zu werden, dann bringt das nichts. Dann bringt es nichts, weil die LP-Adresse da ist. Aber es verhindert, dass so Sachen wie was für einen Browser verwende ich?
Dass ein großer Online-Buchversender weiß, was ich mir die letzten Wochen für Bücher angeguckt habe. Das ist ja auch schon mal ganz praktisch. Schließlich geht es denen nichts an, für welche Bücher ich mich interessiere. Und es ist ja schon bemerkenswert, was sie bisweilen für Zeug empfehlen. Das ist zum Teil enorm nah dran an dem tatsächlichen Interesse, das ich an der Literatur habe. Bisweilen auch komplett weit weg, weil irgendjemand zufällig sich gerade mein Notebook ausgeliehen hat und mal irgendwie kurz geklickt hat, ob es dieses Buch gibt. Damit bekommt man irgendwie vier Wochen CDs, Empfehlungen von Brian Ferry, keine Ahnung.
Also es ist nur so ein bisschen so ein Staubtuch, was man so über seine Verbindung fährt, sodass nicht ganz so viele Daten übertragen werden, wie das sonst der Fall ist, sondern eben nur das, was wirklich für die Kommunikation auch nötig ist. Transparent heißt, man merkt nicht, dass man ihn benutzt? Man muss ihn nicht eintragen als Proxy?
Man muss ihn als Proxy eintragen, aber das können auch die Installationsprogramme. Na ja, das können die Installationsprogramme. Wenn du ihn installierst, kannst du sagen, trag den Fest in meinem Browser ein, und zwar in Internet Explorer und Firefox und Camino, nämlich fürs ungefiltert Surfen oder was auch immer. Und dann ist er da eingetragen. Und wäscht das raus. Dann kannst du halt Regeln sagen, die er auswaschen soll. Der kann praktischerweise halt auch Werbung ausfiltern. Dafür gibt es Software wie AdBlock, aber das ist ganz praktisch, das in Privoxy zu machen. Dann filtest du einerseits Informationen gegenüber Dritten, auch Werbetreibenden, und du wirst die Werbung weg, damit du sie dir nicht angucken musst. Das kostet halt Aufmerksamkeit.
Und du hast es dann automatisch auch mit jeder Software, die du dann benutzt, zum Web-Brosen.
Und das ist aber nur ein Schritt. Und das erlaubt es zunächst nur gegenüber deinem Kommunikationspartner. Dann hast du aber etabliert, was du deinem Kommunikationspartner sagen möchtest, nämlich gib mir mal die Website drüber, Alter. Und dieser Vorgang ist beobachtbar von ihm und von anderen. Nun kann man mit Verschlüsselung sicherstellen, dass der Inhalt dieser Kommunikation Dritten gegenüber nicht ersichtlich wird. Das ist ein Schritt. Das erlaubt aber immer noch, wie gesagt...
Bist du jetzt noch beim Web?
Ich bin noch beim Web, klar.
Verschlüsselung vom Web, also beim HTTP, HTTPS benutzt. Da hat man ja nicht die Wahl. Das hängt ja sozusagen von der Website ab. Also wenn man selber einen Server aufsetzt, wo Leute kommunizieren, man ist sozusagen in der Administratorrolle, dann sollte man darüber nachdenken, ob man das nicht mal anbietet.
Nichtsdestotrotz aber ruhig auch alle Inhalte unverschlüsselt, da komme ich dann gleich noch drauf. Dann besteht immer noch die Notwendigkeit, den Vorgang zwischen Teilnehmer A und B zu verschleiern. Das ist die Frage gegenüber wem. Wenn ich das gegenüber einem Webserver verschleiern möchte, kann ich einen offenen Proxy nehmen. Zum Beispiel bietet ein amerikanisches Unternehmen das an. Man weiß nicht aus welcher Handlungsmotivation heraus. Mutmaßungen waren früher immer, dass die Nachrichten dienstlich finanziert sind, um zu gucken, wenn Leute offensichtlich ein erhöhtes Schutzbedürfnis haben. Ich will den Namen nicht nennen, um keine Verleumdungsklage an den Hals zu bekommen. Aber es gibt einen Proxy, der angeboten wird, um genau diese Verschleierung gegenüber der Webseite vorzunehmen. Das ist die Frage, wer finanziert die eigentlich?
Ist klar, was diese Software macht?
Diese Software bietet dir einen Proxy, so wie viele Open-Proxys auch. Ein Proxy ist ein Stellvertreter, der für dich eine Webseite abruft und sie dir weiterreicht. Das ist im Unternehmensnetz ganz praktisch, wenn 300 Leute jeden Tag die selbe Seite aufrufen, dann muss sie nicht 300 Mal abgerufen werden, sondern einmal, bis sie sich ändert. Der Cash gibt ihr raus, z.B. das Mittagsmenü in der Kantine. Das kann man den ganzen Tag übercashen, weil das ändert sich nicht. Dann sieht der Webserver nur noch die Adresse dieses Stellvertreters. Und im Zweifel auch nur noch einmal und nicht 300 Mal. Aber der Stellvertreter sieht natürlich, was du abgerufen hast. Das Problem ist, es verlagert es vom Webserver, von dem du die Seite abrufst, auf den Stellvertreter. Der muss also weiterhin vertrauenswürdig sein. Du verschiebst das Vertrauen nur. Das ist aber schon mal ein Schritt. Du kannst entscheiden, wem du das Vertrauen zuteilst. Darüber hinaus möchtest du ja möglicherweise diesem Stellvertreter nicht vertrauen müssen. Also kannst du zwei Stellvertreter zwischen dich und denjenigen schalten. Das heißt, der Tim, der fragt den Peter. Und der Peter fragt die Simone. Und die Simone fragt dann die Claudia. Und dann sprichst du nicht mehr Claudia. Und die beiden Stellvertreter wissen auch nur voneinander. Und nicht von voneinander und einem Kommunikationsfeilnehmer.
Werd mal praktisch. Reden wir jetzt über etwas, was sich irgendwie mühelos auf jedem Laptop installieren lässt?
Das ist sozusagen der nächste Schritt hin zu diesen Anonymisierungssoftware, die es jetzt gibt.
War das jetzt ein theoretisches Beispiel oder beziehst du dich praktisch?
Nee, das ist ein praktisches Beispiel. Ich klick... Werd mal genauer. Ich nehme ein Proxy und dann kann ich mit einer Webseite reden. Und die Webseite sieht den Proxy, der Proxy sieht aber mich. Schalte ich zwei Proxys dazwischen, dann sieht der erste Proxy mich, aber nicht das Ziel. Und der zweite Proxy sieht das Ziel, aber nicht mich.
Okay, aber dieser zweite Proxy ist ja dann im Idealfall im Internet.
Genau, der erste auch.
Also den benutze ich nicht... Der erste auch. Okay, gut, ja, verstehe. Also das geht... Es ist also doch nicht so einfach, weil das geht ja davon aus, dass man auch selber einen Server betreibt. Das ist ja nun heutzutage noch nicht unbedingt jedermanns Sache. Mal eben irgendwo beim Internet-Service-Provider sich so ein Host zu klicken, unter Dienste zu laufen zu lassen. Aber vielleicht kriegt man ja sozusagen den Nerd vor Ort, so den Haus-Nerd dazu, sowas mal einzurichten.
Naja, Anonymität funktioniert auch nur in der Gruppe. Wenn nur ich diesen Proxy, diesen Stellvertreter verwende, dann ist es immer noch rückvollziehbar, dass ich es bin. Dann können wir beide im Chaos Computer Club Berlin sitzen und über den Proxy klicken. Dann weiß derjenige nicht mehr, dass es der Tim oder der Andreas ist, aber er weiß trotzdem, dass es jemand aus dem Chaos Computer Club Berlin ist. Nachdem sich da nur ein definiertes Set von im Jahr unter 300-400 Leuten aufhalten, eindeutigen Leuten, ist es immer noch eine enge Gruppe.
Die üblichen Verdächtigen.
Genau.
Ja, das stimmt. Das heißt, man muss die Gruppe möglichst groß machen?
Genau, das heißt, man nimmt einen Proxy, die man sich mit anderen teilt. Das ist das Konzept von Anonymisierungssoftware. Du stellst einen Proxy bereit, der deine und die Kommunikation vieler anderer verschleiert. Und die tun das auch. Und du suchst dir einen Weg zwischen diesen Rechnern.
Aber dann muss ich natürlich auch diesen Betreibern dieses Proxys so weit vertrauen, dass dort keine Daten anfallen, die das Ganze wieder hinfällig machen.
Genau, und jetzt spreche ich nochmal ein bisschen tatsächlich in das Konkrete rein. Die erste wirkliche Anonymisierungssoftware zu bezeichnen, ist JAP, der Java-Anon-Proxy. Das ist ein Proxy, den du dir installierst, lokal, den du dir in den Traffic übergibst. Und der spricht mit einer sogenannten Kaskade von Mixen. Die nennen es nicht mehr Proxy, sondern Mix, weil das ein Proxy ist, der die Kommunikation verschiedener Leute durcheinander würfelt.
Also das ist eine konkrete Software, die kommt aus Deutschland, richtig?
Die kommt aus Deutschland, die beruht auf einem wissenschaftlichen Papier, was Professor Andreas Pfitzmann geschrieben hat. Er ist derjenige, der letztlich Anonymität nach Europa gebracht hat. Das gab es in der amerikanischen wissenschaftlichen Diskussion schon ein bisschen vorher, aber auch nicht in dem Maße. Er ist auf jeden Fall einer derjenigen, die Anonymität in Datennetzen in die Welt gebracht haben und ganz sicher, der das nach Deutschland getragen hat. Der verfügt über einen Lehrstuhl an meinem Institut der Technischen Universität Dresden an der Fakultät für Informatik und hat 1984, glaube ich, ein Papier geschrieben, wie man im ISTN Mixe einrichtet, um Kommunikationsvorgänge zu verschleiern. Also das, was jetzt Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist, hat er einfach 23 Jahre vorher gesehen und gesagt, was könnte man da technisch dagegen tun?
1984.
Nagel mich nicht auf das Jahr fest, aber das Paper findet man.
Das würde ja auf jeden Fall gut passen. Aber er war auf jeden Fall schon in den 80er Jahren dabei, also auch einer der wenigen, die schon frühzeitig gesehen haben, worauf das alles hinausläuft. Letzten Endes ist das ja auch einer der Gründe, warum der CCC sich gegründet hat.
Letztlich.
Okay, also JAB heißt diese Software.
Genau, die wurde finanziert.
Das hieß auch mal Java.
Die wurde finanziert aus Mitteln des Bundeswirtschaftsministeriums, die damals gesagt haben, wir möchten unbeobachtbare Kommunikation im Internet sicherstellen. Da gab es mal einen wachen Moment offensichtlich im Hause.
Das Bundeswirtschaftsministerium?
Ja, es ist ja auch so, wenn man letztlich von Geheimschutz und Spionageabwehr spricht, das sind auch die Themenfelder, was ich sehr spannend finde, wo die Deutschen immer noch mal aufwachen. Wir sind nun mal Exportweltmeister. Wir haben hier keine besonders großen Flächen. Wir haben keine nennenswerte Agrarwirtschaft. Wir haben keine Bodenschätze. Sondern es war hier halt ein Ingenieurbüro, die das umgesetzt haben und produziert haben. Also der deutsche Mittelstand, da gibt es echte Perlen. Die sind Weltmarktführer. Nicht im negativen Sinn wie dieser großartige Spielfilm, den man hier noch mal erwähnen kann. Weltmarktführer, die Geschichte des Tann Siegmann. Kann man jedem nur ans Herz legen, können wir vielleicht dann in die Begleitungsdoku zur Sendung aufnehmen.
Genau, es gibt natürlich wie immer die tollen Links auf der Webseite und in der Datei. So werde ich auch das hier einbauen. So, wenn du mir da eine passende URL lernst, das wirst du sicherlich tun.
weltmarktführerderfilm.de Oh, alles klar, toll. Und es gibt also in der deutschen Industrie Firmen, die auf dem Weltmarkt führen sind und zum Teil auch im produzierenden Bereich tätig, also Maschinenbauer, beispielsweise Anlagenbauer, die aber letztlich Know-how verwalten, Intellectual Property Assets. Und da geht es um Spionage-Schutz. Und da hat das Bundeswirtschaftsministerium tatsächlich seine Aufgabe erfüllt und gesagt, wir möchten gerne Software entwickeln, dies erlaubt, dass unsere Unternehmen dieses geistige Eigentum schützen. Und dazu gehört natürlich auch, wenn ich Patentrecherche mache, dass ich das unbeobachtbar tue, dass es nicht klar ist, diese Patentrecherche stammt von dieser Werft, diesem Maschinenbauer, diesem was auch immer. Das willst du halt nicht, dass du als Absenderadresse in der RIPE-Datenbank steht Ingenieurbüro Schulze und Müller.
So, und das hat das Bundeswirtschaftsministerium dann auch irgendwann mal eingesehen und tatsächlich die Entwicklung dieser Software finanziert, ganz konkret Geld beigesteuert. Weißt du so in welchen Größenordnungen das so ist? Okay, aber irgendwie so sehr, dass es dazu geführt hat, dass es diese Software auch tatsächlich gibt. Wie funktioniert denn das? Also was macht dieses JAP?
Das ist ein Java-Proxy. Das hieß früher auch Java-Anon-Proxy. Später hieß es nur JAP, weil es dann das Recht an einem Java hält. Man darf nichts mehr Kaffee nennen, zumindest nicht im Bereich Software und Informatik. Und diese Software sorgt dafür, dass Kommunikationsverbindungen nicht mehr vom Browser zum Webserver stattfinden, sondern über zwei, anfangs zwei, inzwischen drei Stellvertreter, die sogenannten Mixe, die sind an der Kaskade verschaltet und die sind fest verschaltet. Das heißt, die Reihenfolge ist vorgegeben über die, die abgefragt werden, die verschlüsseln untereinander und die kennen nur einen Teil des Kommunikationswegs.
Das heißt, das sieht so aus, wenn ich das benutzen will und mit einem Browser benutzen will, dann trage ich wieder mal, wie das so schön ist, einen Proxy ein. Das heißt, ich sage meinem Webbrowser, du surfst jetzt nicht dahin, wo ich dir sage, sondern du nimmst diese Adresse, von der ich gerne möchte, dass deren Informationen bei mir erscheinen und dann schickst du sie an diesen Stellvertreter, an diesen Proxy. Genau, der läuft auf dem lokalen Rechner. Normalerweise, wie du schon gesagt hast, auf meinem Rechner.
Genau, als Java-Software.
Um das auch nochmal klarzumachen, Proxys sind normalerweise eher dazu gedacht gewesen, die Performance zu unterstützen. Teilweise hat man sie auch so in Anführungsstrichen als Firewall benutzt, um Schlimmeres zu verhindern. Das ist natürlich keine gute Idee, aber auch sowas gibt es. Und in diesem Fall soll es eben anonymisieren. Das heißt, ich muss diese Software nehmen und auf meinem Rechner zum Laufen kriegen.
Genau.
Und das läuft dann, weil es Java ist, sowieso fast überall. Und dann, was macht dann diese Software mit meinem Webrequest?
Du musst dort eine Mixkaskade aussuchen. Das heißt, du musst eine der vorhandenen Kaskaden wählen. Eine Kaskade ist...
Zum Zeitpunkt der Installation?
Nee, das kannst du zur Laufzeit machen. Du siehst auch, wie viel Traffic da gerade drauf ist.
Wie zur Laufzeit? Das heißt, jedes Mal, wenn ich irgendwo einen Link anklicke, muss ich vorher noch auswählen, wo ich langgehen soll?
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Du wählst, also bei der Installation ist eine Kaskade ausgewählt, glaube ich. Also war zumindest immer so irgendeine. Und du kannst sie jederzeit wählen, musst es aber nicht tun. Kannst aber sehen, wie stabil ist die gerade, wie schnell ist die gerade, seit wie vielen Tagen funktioniert die. Und kannst sie halt eine, wie viele Nutzer sind da drauf, je mehr Nutzer. Woran sehe ich das? Es gibt einen kleinen Monitor in diesem Java-Plugin. Also das ist dann so ein Icon, das dir sagt, hier sind 300 User, damit hast du gute Anonymität.
Oder die sagt, hier sind 20 User.
Genau.
Okay, alles klar. Richtig so, als hoffe für einen Desktop.
Verstehe.
Und dann wählst du eine Kaskade.
Und Kaskade heißt, das ist dann sozusagen eine...
Ein Verbund von...
Rechnern....
von Mixen.
Die irgendwo sind.
Genau.
Und wie viele gibt es davon? Also, wie sie...
Ungefähr fünf Kaskaden. Kann noch mal gerade gucken.
Und an jeder nehmen so ein paar Rechner teil?
Drei Stück. Früher waren es zwei, jetzt sind es drei. Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht Kaskaden sind es inzwischen. Genau. Und dort sind zwei Rechner ursprünglich beteiligt gewesen. Der erste, die Entry-Note, wo der Datenverkehr reinkommt, die Anfrage vom Benutzer, und die Exit-Note, wo der Datenverkehr reinkommt, die Anfrage vom Benutzer, und die Exit-Note, wo der Datenverkehr reinkommt, die Anfrage vom Benutzer, und die Entry-Note, wo der Datenverkehr reinkommt, die Anfrage vom Benutzer, und die Exit-Note, wo der Datenverkehr reinkommt, die Anfrage vom Benutzer, und die Exit-Note, die diese Anfrage wieder rausgibt an den Web-Server.
Also was heißt, er kennt nur den Browser, also er kennt natürlich auch meine IP-Adresse, von wem das Ganze ausgegangen ist.
Genau, aber er weiß nicht, wohin diese Anfrage geht, denn diese Anfrage wird zweifach verschlüsselt. Nämlich, du verschlüsselst diese Anfrage an den zweiten Mix, und dann verschlüsselst du das an den ersten Mix und gibst ihm das. Das heißt, der erste Mix bekommt ein Datenpaket, entpackt es und entschlüsselt es, und sieht, das gehört an den zweiten, reicht es dem weiter, der packt es wieder aus, und reicht es weiter. Letztlich ist das so ein Zwiebelschalen-Modell. Du nimmst also ein Stück Papier, schreibst drauf www.ccc.de, rollst es ein, packst es in einen Briefumschlag, auf den schreibst du drauf Mix Exit Note, packst es wieder in einen Kuvert, schreibst drauf Mix Entry Note und gibst dieses Kuvert der Entry Note. Der sieht also, von dir kommt etwas, das ist für ihn, das macht er auf, da steht drin Exit Note und gibt es weiter. Mehr von dieser Kommunikationsbeziehung sieht er nicht.
Also nicht nur, dass er es nicht macht, er kann auch nicht reinschauen, weil es durch die Verschlüsselung verhindert wird.
Genau, das ist eine technische Verhinderung, um diese Anonymität aufzuheben.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo das Paket hinten wieder rauskommt, aus dieser Kaskade und dann zu dem eigentlichen Server geht, kann dieser Server nicht mehr sehen, von wem es eigentlich kam, sondern er sieht stattdessen diese Adresse von diesem Exit-Note. Das heißt, im Zweifelsfall, wenn man es drauf anlegt, weiß man aber, ok, da ist jetzt was von so einem Anonymizer gekommen. Das ist unter Umständen Schweinkram und das sind alles Kinderpornografen usw.
Das hat auch den Vorteil, dass man filtern kann.
Oder der Mittelstand in Deutschland natürlich.
Man kann ja sagen, wenn etwas von einer Anonymizer Exit-Note kommt, dann möchte ich diesem nur einen Lesezugriff geben. Weil natürlich ist Vandalismus möglich, wenn man sich hinter Anonymitate verstecken kann. Sodass du jetzt Wikipedia nicht editieren kannst, wenn du aus einer Anonymizer Note kommst, dann lässt du sie keinen Edit zu, bis du dich nicht anmeldest. Wenn du dich anmeldest und eine gültige Mail-Adresse hast, also dein Anonymitate ihnen gegenüber aufhebst, lassen sie das zu. Und das ist ja auch ein wichtiger Aspekt. Du redest von der deutschen Wikipedia?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es bei der Englischen so ist, keine Ahnung. Bei der Englischen gibt es ja eh noch Einschränkungen mit neuem Artikel anlegen, sowieso nur für registrierte Benutzer und so weiter. Aber natürlich gibt es auch dort anonyme Editierungen. Insofern hat das Stimmen.
Nichtsdestotrotz...
Ich bringe dich die ganze Zeit aus den Konzerten. Aber es liegt auch daran, dass du diese leckeren Schokokicks mitgebracht hast. Wie heißen die denn eigentlich?
Ich mache keine Schleichwerbung, aber die sind sehr fein. Ja, das ist gut.
Du hast ja noch Club Marr-Tee. Das gehört natürlich zu jedem Podcast dazu.
Ich muss auch noch mal ein bisschen...
Ich hoffe, ihr verzeiht, dass wir ein bisschen essen. Wir verwöhnen uns ja nur, dass wir jetzt nicht zu seriös rüberkommen.
Erfrischend und belebend.
Genau, das ist ja immerhin ein Podcast. Ein alternatives Medium. Genau, im Babygeschrei, im Hintergrund ist alles super. Ich trinke jetzt noch was und du kannst mal weiter erklären.
Ich quatsche mal weiter ins Internet. Die Anonymität, die mir diese Kaskade bietet, kann ich jederzeit selbst aufheben. Wenn ich in diese Information, die ich dem Webserver übermittele, reinschreibe, meine Kontonummer ist, dann weiß der natürlich, wer ich bin. Das mag er auch erfordern, um die Dienste nutzen zu können. Die Wikipedia sagt, wer bist denn du? Bevor du hier rumschmierst, gib mir mal deinen Namen. Das ist auch völlig legitim. Aber es bietet mir die Option, Anonymität zu haben und sie zu einem beliebigen Zeitpunkt aufzuheben, wenn ich das möchte. Selektiv gegenüber denen, gegenüber denen ich es möchte. Und nicht von vornherein, wenn ich das Netz betrete. So ein bisschen wie auf einer Party. Da kann ich auch auf Leute zugehen und sagen, hallo, ich bin Andreas. Ich muss aber nicht mit einem großen Schild über den Kopf zur Tür reinkommen und sagen, ich bin Andreas. Ich brauch's einfach nicht.
Ja, stimmt. Und vor allem Wikipedia ist vielleicht auch ein gutes Beispiel, wenn ich irgendwie in der Wikipedia den Eintrag über meditante Gruppenreden, den es bestimmt geben wird, die ganze Zeit lese, dann bin ich ja genauso verdächtig, als wenn ich mir die entsprechenden Informationen auf der BKA-Webseite durchlese, um auch mal bei dem Beispiel zu bleiben.
Und du kannst es mühelos lesen und anonym bleiben, wenn du aber reinschreiben willst, musst du dich halt im Zweifel outen.
Also wenn ich selber Informationen über unsere Organisation beitragen möchte.
Letztlich ist es aber so, dass die Anonymität aufhebbar ist. Wenn beide Teile dieser Kaskade zusammenarbeiten, ist es aufhebbar. Weswegen man auch aus anderen Gründen noch einen Dritten etabliert hat.
Ach so, wenn B, der das ja... Also ich sag jetzt mal, dieser Entry-Note ist irgendwie A und B geht's hinten wieder raus. Das heißt, wenn B und A sich verschwören gegen mich und sagen irgendwie lalalalala, dann haben die alle Informationen, die sie wissen müssen und können einfach so, können auch vor allem gleich dann dem Bedarfsträger sozusagen auch gleich Bescheid sagen.
Falls er sie nicht eh betreibt.
Da kommen wir später dazu, das ist beim JAP-Note so, man muss zwar der Universität und Andreas Pfitzmann mehr oder weniger Vertrauen schenken über die Software. Man muss den Betreibern der Kaskaden Vertrauen schenken, aber das ist auf eine Art noch nachvollziehbar. Es ist auch so, dass das BKA eine Abhörschnittstelle erzwungen hat in JAP. Also es gibt dort einen definierten Weg, um die Anonymität von Teilnehmern aufzuheben, sofern eine von einem Richter ausgestellte Überwachungsanordnung vorliegt, nach Katalogstraftaten 100 AB oder GH-Strafprozessordnung. Das ließ sich nicht verhindern, weil sowohl der Software-Entwickler als auch die Betreiber dieser Kaskaden auf deutschem Boden sitzen und damit Gegenstand des deutschen Rechtsraums sind. Das muss man im Zweifel aber auch akzeptieren, und ich bin auch gewillt, das zu akzeptieren. Wir wollen ja nicht einen rechtsfreien Raum schaffen, was ab und zu von Politikern, die sich das Internet ausdrucken lassen, dem Internet vorgeworfen wird. Es gibt auch ein sehr schönes Bild zur Eröffnung des gemeinsamen Internetzentrums des BKA, wo sich Herr Schäuble mal das Internet ausdrucken lässt, falls man mal gute Laune bekommen will am Morgen, wenn es kalt ist und regnet, das ist super. Diese Menschen entscheiden über das Internet, weißt du? Und die lassen sich das von ihrer Sekretärin ausdrucken, vorlesen, diktieren und antworten, die wird dann per Fax zurückgeschickt.
Genau, wir wollen nicht, dass es ein rechtsfreier Raum wird, weil, wir haben ja schon gelernt, rechtssichert Freiheit.
Genau. Und insofern akzeptieren wir auch, dass es in Deutschland Möglichkeiten geben muss, um bei Katalogstraftaten diese Anonymität aufzuheben. Und auch alle Betreiber sind sich einig, wir, die wir dafür gerade stehen, die wir mit unserer Arbeitszeit, mit der wissenschaftlichen Arbeit, mit der Entwicklungsarbeit, mit dem Code, mit dem Geld, das es kostet, diese Rechner zu betreiben, die wir dafür einstehen, dass es unbeobachtbare Räume in Form von Kommunikationen gibt und geben kann und geben muss. Wir wollen uns nicht vor Leute stellen, die bestimmte Katalogstraftaten eines abschließenden Katalogs ausüben. Ich will mich nicht vor Kinderpornografen stellen. Die haben einfach überhaupt kein Recht. Die haben da nichts verloren. Die sollen mal weggehen. Und ich muss mich auch nicht vor einen Mörder stellen. Wirklich nicht. Und dafür kann es Wege geben. Und das ist auch offensichtlich der einzige Weg, um das zu machen. Das ist natürlich auch für uns ein schwieriges Abwägungsgefühl.
Für uns als CCC, als Betreiber, eine solche Kaskade. Genau, das haben wir ja noch gar nicht erwähnt. Also es gibt nicht nur diese Software. Und das ist nicht nur die TU Dresden, sondern auch der CCC hat sich entschlossen, einen solchen Dienst anzubieten. Gibt es da noch irgendwas Besonderes zu erwähnen? Zu unserem Angebot? Oder ist das so wie alle anderen auch?
Wie alle anderen auch.
Das heißt, es ist eigentlich nur so die Entscheidung, okay, wir finanzieren einen Rechner.
Und den Traffic da anfällt, um das zu betreiben.
Und jemand, der sich kümmert und so weiter, dass das Ding auch läuft und wieder hochkommt, wenn es mal nicht läuft.
Ja, und auch Ansprechpartner zu sein. Wenn irgendein Missbrauch stattfindet oder der Verdacht auf Missbrauch vorliegt, dann sieht ja derjenige, bei dem das stattgefunden hat. Also im klassischen Fall irgendjemand, der ein PHP-Bulletinboard hat, wo jemand reingeschrieben hat, du riechst nach Lulu, das ist eine Beleidigung, dann will er da möglicherweise Anzeige erstatten und dann sieht er, diese Beleidigung kommt von einem Rechner des Chaos Computer Clubs mit der Adresse 84. Und wendet sich an uns und sagt, einer eurer Mitglieder hat mich beleidigt. Dann sagen wir, nee, keiner unserer Mitglieder hat sie beleidigt. Das läge uns auch ferne.
Also wir wissen nicht, ob es einer unserer Mitglieder war.
Möglicherweise, aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist recht gering.
Denn wir wissen nicht, wer es war. Aber sollte sich jetzt wirklich eine Straftat nach einem dieser Paragrafen, die du vorhin erzählt hast, nachweisen lassen und dann kommt dann eine höchstrichterliche Anfrage. In dem Moment würden wir den umsetzen. Und was würde dann herausgegeben werden? Eine IP-Adresse und einen Zeitpunkt.
Eine IP-Adresse und ein Zeitstempel. Allerdings nur in die Zukunft gerichtet.
Es werden keine Daten gelockt.
Nein, es wird nicht gelockt. Das heißt, wir können rückwirkend keine Daten herausgeben. Das ist auch bedeutsam. Und das ist ja das Argument für die Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Genau, sonst hätten wir da Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Dass man Kommunikationsdaten in die Vergangenheit hat. Eine solche Überwachungsmaßnahme kann nur in die Zukunft gerichtet sein. Sicherlich hemmt es die Strafverfolgung. Das schränkt die ein. Aber auch das Fernwellegeheimnis schränkt das ein. Auch die Menschenwürde schränkt Strafverfolgung ein. So ist das nun mal. Das ist halt der demokratische Prozess. Da gibt es Güterabwägungen. Wenn man die getroffen hat, dann muss man sich dran halten. Dann kann man im Zweifel darüber sprechen, ob man die Regeln verändern will. Aber dann muss das Teil des demokratischen Prozesses sein, muss auf einer legitimierten Weg stattfinden. Und dann kann man darüber sprechen. Insofern sind wir auch bereit, jetzt erst mal in die Zukunft gerichtet, solche Maßnahmen vorzunehmen. Das ist auch das, was wir den Nutzern kommunizieren. Das bietet keine 100-prozentige Anonymität. Aber es bietet eine deutlich bessere Anonymität als ohne. Auch weil eine Vollüberwachung nicht stattfindet, nicht stattfinden wird, nicht stattfinden darf. Und technisch ausgeschlossen ist. Allerdings ist es halt schon schwierig zu sagen, man hat eine Schnittstelle, die es erlaubt, von Hand einen Kommunikationsvorgang nach einem Filterkriterium auszusatieren. Das kam auch bisher ein einziges Mal vor, dass wir verpflichtet wurden, das zu tun, seit wir das betreiben, seit fast drei Jahren. Und hat auch kein Ergebnis gebracht. Aber es wurde einmal angeordnet. Ich nehme an, die wollten auch mal gucken, würden wir uns dem fügen oder stellen wir uns ja außerhalb des Gesetzes. Und das tun wir nicht. Wir sind ein deutscher Verein. Ich bin als Vorstand Vertreter einer deutschen juristischen Person. Und dann halten wir uns natürlich auch an deutsches geltendes Recht. Aber wir wollen auch darüber diskutieren, wie das zustande kommt.
Jetzt sind wir ja im Prinzip schon bei dem ersten Teil dieses CCC-Anonymizer-Dienstes. Gibt es zu JAP noch etwas Wichtiges zu erwähnen, was wir jetzt noch nicht gesagt haben?
Ja, die Förderung ist ausgelaufen.
Genau, Geld, darauf wollte ich jetzt eigentlich gerade kommen. Ach so, die Förderung für das JAP-Projekt selber ist ausgelaufen.
Die Kaskaden, die betrieben werden, werden unter anderem von uns, unsere Kaskade ist noch mit einem ISP zusammen betrieben und mit einer Node in Dresden.
Und diese Kaskade, da hatte ich dich vorhin, glaube ich, unterbrochen. Die hat jetzt drei Rechner.
Genau, das sind das JAP-Themen, die Firma Speedpartner, das ist eine ISP, die beschlossen haben, sie wollen ihren Kunden diese Möglichkeit bieten und setzen sich dafür ein, weil sie das gut finden und die Bandbreite überhaben und wir als CCC. Und dann gibt es halt noch andere, die das auch machen, die Rechner bereitstellen und bezahlen, damit diese Kaskaden existieren. Die sind aber alle fixe Kaskaden und sie sind, soweit ich weiß, nahezu alle auf deutschem Boden.
Also fix heißt, die Konfiguration ändert sich nicht.
Die Reihenfolge ändert sich nicht, genau. Und es besteht eben technisch die Möglichkeit, diese Anonymität aufzuheben, wenn auch nur unter sehr eingeschränkterer Bedingungen und nur in die Zukunft gerichtet, aber das kann stattfinden. Weswegen es auch inzwischen den Vorschlag gab aus der Politik, dass man ja für Anonymisierungsdienste eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung und eine LI-Schnittstelle einführen müsste. Ich weiß nicht, was sich die dabei denken. Also wer sowas fordert, ist ja nicht bei Trost.
LI, Lawful Interception ist da der Begriff. Das gesetzesbasierte Abfangen von Daten. Aber auch das Projekt des CCC kann ja Spenden gebrauchen, denke ich mal.
Oh ja, allerdings ist es so, dass wir eine einzige Note in diesem JAP-System betreiben. Das ist technisch nicht so interessant. Das ist aber interessant, einfach weiter zu betreiben. Wir haben damit angefangen, das war das erste, was wir getan haben. Das wollen wir auch weiter betreiben. Schon auch, um Alternativen zu haben. Auch um auszuloten, welches Verfahren besser funktioniert. Das geht uns ja auch um Forschungsbetrieb. Es geht schon darum, Dritten diese Möglichkeit zu bieten, anonym zu kommunizieren. Aber es ist auch klar, solange nur zehn Leute oder hier sieben mal drei 21 Rechner an diesen Kaskaden beteiligt sind, ist das ja nie flächendeckend möglich. Es ist halt ein Forschungsbetrieb, um herauszufinden, wie funktioniert diese Software, wem kann die nützen, was kann die tun. Um mit Leuten ins Gespräch darüber zu kommen, ist Anonymität in Datennetzen denn ein wichtiges Gut? Wollen wir das als Gesellschaft, wenn ja, unter welchen Rahmenbedingungen, unter welchen Einschränkungen?
Das heißt, wem würdest du jetzt zum Beispiel die Nutzung von so einem JAPS-System?
Nur eine Sekunde. Und da haben wir den großen Vorteil, dass wir eine Dauerspende bekommen für den Betrieb dieser Maschine. Ein befreundeter Anwalt spendet uns einfach Geld dafür, dass wir diese Maschine betreiben können. Von Anfang an. Darüber hinaus gibt es ein weiteres System, das technisch ein bisschen ausgereifter ist, das Tor-System, die Onion-Router. Das ist letztlich vom Konzept her das Gleiche. Also auch ein System von Stellvertretern. Allerdings geht es darüber hinaus, JAP geht grundsätzlich nur für Web-Zugriffe. Das war unbeobachtbare Web-Zugriffe zu realisieren, das funktioniert auch, das war auch das Ziel. Aber nicht mehr. Sehr viel flexibler ist Tor. Das ist eine Entwicklung, die ein Student am MIT gemacht hat, zusammen mit dem Navy Research Lab, also einer Forschungseinrichtung der Seestreitkräfte der Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika. Die beschlossen haben, dass sie gerne unbeobachtbare Kommunikation hätten und das mal ausprobieren wollen, wie da der Stand der Dinge ist, was man da realisieren kann. Daraus entstand dann The Onion Router. Und einer der Programmierer, Roger Dingeldine, hat dann mit Unterstützung der EFF, der Electronic Frontier Foundation, also sowas wie unsere Schwesterorganisation in den Staaten, mehr oder weniger allerdings eher in die Bürgerrechtsschiene, also stärker als auf die technische Schiene gehend, das Ganze nochmal umgesetzt als TOR, als diesen neuen Code darum. Daher kommt auch die Adresse tor.eff.org, das ist die Website, unter der das verfügbar ist.
Die Onion Router, also der Zwiebel-Weiterleiter.
Da hatten wir ja vorhin schon kurz das mit den verschiedenen Brief-Kovers, letztlich sind es auch nur Zwiebelschalen, ist halt die Frage nach der Vorstellung.
Das heißt auch Tor basiert auf der Idee, dass man seine Datenkommunikation durch eine Kaskade anderer Rechner schickt, um sozusagen da Haken zu schlagen, um das mal so ganz salopp zu formulieren, weil am Ende hinten, wie Herr Kohl immer so schön sagte, wichtig ist, was jetzt rauskommt und da kann man halt nicht mehr sehen, wo es herkommt. Und die Verschlüsselung bei Tor, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, sind dann mehrere Rechner beteiligt, nicht nur ein paar.
Der Vorteil an Tor ist, dass diese Kaskade dynamisch ist. Das heißt, jede Note ist abhängig von ihrer Konfiguration. Du kannst Regelgesetze definieren, nicht nur für HTTP und HTTPS eine Exit-Note, sondern auch für mögliche andere Dienste wie IMAP, wie SSH, wie was man auch immer nutzen möchte. Das ist also flexibel, das ist nicht nur ein Webproxy, sondern ein sogenanntes Overlay-Network. Das heißt, es ist ein Socks-Proxy, Socks ist Socket-Proxy, die Möglichkeit, beliebige TCP-Kommunikation durch einen Dritten zu tunneln. Das war eine Erfindung von MIPS, glaube ich, was dann zu Silicon Graphics ging und dazu diente, um zum Beispiel durch Firewalls rausgehen zu können, dass du also von deinem Computer aus nicht direkt mit Dritten Kontakt aufnehmen darfst, aber es einen dedizierten Rechner gibt und wenn du den explizit angibst, dann kannst du Kommunikation mit Dritten draußen außerhalb der Firewall aufnehmen, definierte und auch eingehend dem Zweifel weiterleiten.
Also um das gleich nochmal zu verdeutlichen, während JAP sich explizit ausschließlich auf die Kommunikation eines Webbrowsers beschränkt, also in der Regel HTTP oder eben auch HTTPS oder halt auch die anderen Ports, die ja irgendwie noch unter Umständen ins Spiel kommen, geht es jetzt hier sehr viel weiter und versucht eben gleich eine ganze Protokollfamilie abzudecken, aber wohlgemerkt TCP, also die Domänen von verbindungsorientierten Verbindungen. Nicht IP, was darunter liegt, was alles wäre. Das heißt, was da effektiver hinten rausfällt, ist ODP, was nicht so, naja, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass es unwichtig ist. Ohne ODP würde das Internet auch nicht funktionieren. Aber nur ein Teil der Kommunikation, aber vielleicht der relevante Teil, den kann man jetzt umlernen. Aber Socks-Proxy heißt auch, dass man seine Software darauf anpassen muss, dass sie mit diesem Tor überhaupt arbeiten kann. Das geht nicht so out of the box. Ich kann nicht sagen, Tor an und fertig.
Genau, und es gibt auch wenige Web-Browser, die das direkt sprechen können. Weswegen in der Regel mein Tor fürs Websurfen, das war ja gerade der Anwendungszweck von Japp, in Verbindung mit einem HTTP-Proxy, der dann Socks spricht, kombiniert zum Beispiel mit einem Privoxy, der dann auch gleich die Cookies ausfiltert und die Kopfzeilen wäscht. Letztlich ist aber Tor in dieser Hinsicht eben sehr viel flexibler, weil es mehr als nur das Protokoll HTTP und dessen SSL-gesicherte, also verschlüsselte Variante erlaubt, sondern bildfähige Dienste. Darüber hinaus sind die Kaskaden nicht fest. Die müssen bei Japp fest konfiguriert werden, das heißt da müssen sich Betreiber zusammenfinden. Das hat auch den Vorteil, die Betreiber, die sich zusammenfinden, geben eine freiwillige Selbstverpflichtungserklärung ab, in der sie sich verpflichten, nicht mitzuloggen, nicht die Kommunikation zu manipulieren, nicht diesen jenes. Das gibt es bei Tor nicht. Bei Tor kann einfach jeder, der sich die Software installiert, seinen Key schicken und dann taucht er in den Directory-Servers auf, in den Verzeichnungsdiensten unter einer Torn-Note. Und dann kann er auch den ausgehenden Traffic mitlesen.
Das heißt, jeder kann sich da einklinken?
Genau. Es ist auch unklar, wer das ist.
Das heißt, es können auch irgendwelche Böse sein, aber die haben nichts davon, weil alles, was sie kriegen, ist verschlüsselt und alles, was sie weiterleiten, ist auch verschlüsselt?
Das hängt von dir ab. Du kannst natürlich deine Anonymität aufheben. Wenn du Unverschlüsseltes aus der Exit-Note rausfallen lässt, dann kann das die Exit-Note mitlesen. Im Fall von Web-Traffic also, wenn du mit dem Browser nicht HTTPS sprichst, ist die Exit-Note und nur diese in der Lage, den kompletten Datenverkehr mitzulesen. Allerdings weiß sie nicht, wer du bist.
Entrinote, Exit-Note, man hat immer so eine Wolke von Rechnern, da gehen die Daten rein und dann schießen sie sich das gegenseitig so lange hin und her, bis man so das Gefühl hat, dass es jetzt alles ausreichend verschleiert und verschwurbelt, sodass, wenn das dann wieder heraus tritt aus dieser Wolke, man irgendwie nicht mehr so richtig weiß, wo es herkommt. Und so lange ist das alles verschlüsselt, aber zwangsläufig muss natürlich der Datenstrom wieder in seinen ursprünglichen Zustand umgewandelt werden, in dem Moment, wo es aus der Wolke rausschießt und der Rechner, der das dann tut, der sieht natürlich, wie auch derjenige, der es annimmt, sieht natürlich alles.
Ja, nur der, der es annimmt, sieht ja nur Tor-Traffic. Also der Rechner, der es annimmt, also der Entrinote.
Also der weiß auch schon nicht mehr, woher es kommt.
Der weiß, woher es kommt, aber nicht, was es ist. Der sieht einen Haufen Rauschen und weiß, das möchte er jetzt bitte der Middlenote weitergeben, die es dann vielleicht einer Exitnote ergibt.
Ich meine, derjenige, der das sozusagen rausführt und dann ins Internet spuckt.
Der sieht es, genau, aber nicht derjenige, der es annimmt. Der sieht was. Der Teil, an dem ich die Wolke betrete, sieht nur, dass es Traffic für die Wolke ist. Der Punkt, wo ich die Wolke verlasse, ist unverschlüsselt. Hin zum... was auch immer.
Aber er sieht natürlich die IP-Adresse. Das ist das, was ich meinte. Also beim Einstieg ist natürlich...
Genau, der Einstieg sieht die Absenderadresse. Derjenige, der die Wolke verlässt, sieht die Zieladresse.
Nur noch die Zieladresse.
Genau, und der andere sieht nur die Quelladresse. Und diese Zuordnung ist nicht machbar. Und bei Tor gibt es kein Protokoll, das diese Anonymität aufhebt, in dem alle drei beteiligten Rechner ihr Wissen zusammenführen. Nur dann wäre es ja möglich, wenn sie dieses Wissen zusammenführen, herauszufinden, woher und wohin dieses Paket ging.
Und wenn ich jetzt so einen Rechner zur Verfügung stellen will, wenn ich jetzt so sage, ok, alles klar, Tor ist super, die Welt braucht das, wir brauchen mehr Kapazität, ich will jetzt meinen Rechner auch da mit einbringen, kann ich dann einfach dieser Gesamtwolke mich einfach mit einschließen?
Genau, du kannst die Software Tor installieren, kannst einen Regelsatz definieren, welche Datenverkehr du über deinen Rechner erlauben möchtest. Das ist insofern bedeutsam, da kommen wir ja auch gleich noch drauf, als dass, wenn du Exit-Note bist, du ja hatten wir gerade schon, du derjenige bist, der nach außen auftritt, der dann angeschrieben wird, weil es aussieht, als käme die Kommunikation von dir. Das kann man unter anderem erleichtern, indem man an die IP-Adresse der Exit-Note einen Webserver ranmacht und drauf schreibt, dies ist eine Exit-Note. Bei Problemen wenden sie sich bitte an, dass man proaktiv kommuniziert ist, es ist eine Exit-Note, es ist ein Anonymisierungsnetzwerk, Ziel dessen ist und wenn sie ein Problem haben, rufen sie uns an, schreiben sie uns. Es ist auch so, dass wir mit den meisten Leuten ausnehmend gute Erfahrungen gemacht haben. Und es ist auch sehr praktisch.
Die meisten Leuten, die sich beschweren über irgendwas?
Genau, die Leute, die bei uns beim Abuse-Contact auftreten, sagen halt, ich habe da eine Sicherheitslücke in meinem Webserver gehabt und sagen wir, gut, die wurde missbraucht, tut uns leid. Aber das hätte auch passieren können bei jemanden, der von einer nicht-anonymisierten Strecke kommt. Das passiert ja auch regelmäßig. Oder von einem Rechner eines Dritten, der missbraucht wird, um Zugang zu...
Oder ein WLAN, wo man sich eingeloggt hat. Genau, oder Uni oder tralala.
Und es gibt natürlich eine abschließende Liste, also die Directory-Servers, die Verzeichnungsdienste kennen ja alle Anonymisierungsrechner, die da teilnehmen. Das sind jetzt bei Torso um die 1500 oder so. So 1500 Maschinen. Und es gibt eine Liste über diese 1500 Maschinen eben das Verzeichnis, damit ich mir aussuchen kann, durch welche drei von den 1500 möchte ich mir meine dynamische Kaskade legen.
Das heißt, man bestimmt das selber?
Genau, bei Tor bestimmt man das im Gegensatz zu JAB selbst. Und wechselt das auch alle 10 Minuten. Das heißt, selbst wenn jemand überzufähig diese drei Rechner Kontrolle hat, die ich gerade benutze, und das ist ja eine Frage von Wahrscheinlichkeiten, wie viele Server muss ich betreiben, damit die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ich drei aufeinander folgende betreibe, um die komplette Kommunikation zu sehen, die drei suche ich mir selbst aus, würfel ich mir selbst zusammen und würde das jemand kontrollieren, hätte er nur für 10 Minuten einen Blick, weil danach suche ich mir andere.
Das heißt, der CCC-Server, den ihr betreibt, der ist sozusagen auch nur einer von vielen?
Genau, wobei das mehrere sind. Bei Tor betreiben wir inzwischen mehrere Rechner.
Und die fungieren aber auch als Exit-Note?
Die fungieren bei uns alle als Exit-Note und wir haben eine relativ liberale Exit-Policy, was unter anderem darin liegt, dass wir auch das JAP-Projekt-Erfahrungen mit Strafverfolgern gesammelt haben, dass wir immer im Dialog stehen, auch mit Anwälten, dass wir im Dialog stehen mit den Leuten, die das programmieren und gucken, was ist in der Bundesrepublik zulässig. Das tun wir, das Maximallmögliche, sofern es nicht gute Gründe gibt, die dagegen sprechen.
Aber man kann jetzt, wenn man sich dem Netzwerk beimengt, sagen, ich bin einfach nur in der Mitte und will mit nichts weiter zu tun. Ich will nur die Kapazität erhöhen und die gesamte Entropie erhöhen.
Das ist auch am Anfang ganz hilfreich und hängt natürlich auf dem Rechtsraum ab. Die Bundesrepublik ist so, das muss man einfach festhalten, bis dato sehr liberal und erlaubt es.
Solange man das macht, ist man aber auch eigentlich fein raus, weil man eigentlich nichts anderes macht als verschlüsselte Pakete anzunehmen.
Von denen du keine Kenntnisse hast.
Von denen man keine Kenntnisse hat, was sie sind, wohin sie gehen usw. Und man gibt sie dann weiter, genauso verschlüsselt oder anders verschlüsselt, aber immer noch verschlüsselt und man weiß immer noch nicht, was Sache ist. Und das heißt, der CCC betreibt mehrere dieser Exit-Notes? Was heißt mehrere? Sind das jetzt irgendwie so...
Eine Handvoll derzeit.
Paar. Und ist denn da viel los? Also ich meine, ist da viel Traffic?
Wir hatten gerade einen Rechner, der wurde uns vom Anbieter gekündigt, zum Ende der Laufzeit nach einem Jahr, weil sie nicht bereit waren, das fortzuführen, weil dort doch die sehr, sehr liberale Exit-Policy-Abuse angekommen ist, die aber wegen des Massengeschäfts nicht bereit waren, uns als Abuse-Contact einzutragen. Wenn du IP-Adressen als Provider an Kunden vergibst, hast du die Verpflichtung, ab einem Slash-29-Sidernetwork, also acht Adressen am Stück, einen Kontakt einzutragen. Dann schreibst du rein, dieser Netzblock gehört dem Chaos Computer Club, Ansprechpartner ist die Betriebsleitung Anonymisierungsdienste, Rechtsanwalt, Telefon hier anrufen.
Betriebsleitung Anonymisierungsdienste, klingt so, als wären wir bei der Deutschen Telekom angegriffen. Zeitschlitzverfahren, juhu. Also da wurde man nicht eingetragen.
Und die sagen halt, sie wollen das nicht eintragen und es gibt keine Verpflichtung. Das heißt, wir können sie auch nicht dazu zwingen, was wir auch nicht tun wollen würden. Wir wollen ja ein gutes Verhältnis zu den Providern, aber es gibt keine Vorgabe, die Adressen zuteilen, Entität RIPE, bei weniger als acht Adressen des Niedatenbanks einzutragen und bei ein oder zwei Adressen, glaube ich, sogar das Verbot des Einzutragen, weil sonst die Datenbank so unhandlich groß wird. Und die Provider vergeben halt nur eine Adresse und auf explizite Anfrage eine zweite. Man braucht ja auch nur eine eigentlich. Das heißt aber, dass wir, wenn wir dort nicht als Abuse-Contact eingetragen sind, die komplette Kritik auf der Hotline des ISPs ankommt und das macht die unglücklich und das kostet die enorm viel Zeit ohne Aufwand.
Und eine Ausnahme wollen sie auch nicht machen.
Nee, wollten sie nicht machen. Das war der Kündigungsgrund. Und die Maschine hat bis zu ihrer Kündigung, ich habe mir hier neulich noch mal einen Screenshot gemacht, so etwas wie 16 Terabyte im Monat gemacht. Also schon richtig doll Traffic dafür, dass die Kiste 99 Euro gekostet hat.
16 Terabyte in einem Monat?
Na, das geliebt zu der Dienst. Und wir hatten halt auch eine relativ...
Kann man da eine Aussage darüber fallen, wie viele Verbindungen das dann sind? Oder ist das schon auch nicht mehr sichtbar?
Nee, keine Ahnung.
Kann man nur Mutmaßen.
Man kann Mutmaßen, aber ja offensichtlich mehrere Zehntausend.
Ah, das ist schon auch natürlich schon mal interessant. Das heißt, ein Tour-Exit-Note weiß so wenig über den Traffic. Ich meine, er spuckt ja die Pakete hinten raus. Man könnte theoretisch sich die Pakete anschauen und sich da was irgendwie bauen, aber das müsste auch erst gemacht werden. Das will man ja explizit nicht. Das will man nicht, genau. Aber es wäre natürlich theoretisch möglich, dass jemand eine modifizierte Tour-Software fährt und so weiter. Aber er wüsste dann auch nicht so sehr viel mehr.
Tour auf einem Rechner betreibt, bei dem im Zweifel zum Beispiel der Firewall-Code entsprechend umgeschrieben wird mit Countern.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt seinen Rechner... Also im Idealfall hat man so einen Computer, wo man zentral so ein Socks-Proxy angeben kann. Und das heißt, heißt das, dass die Software in der Regel auch unverändert läuft damit?
Wenn es da ein Socks-Proxy gibt, ja, das Problem ist noch, dass auch so eine Überlegung IP einzusetzen statt TCP als Grundlage dieses Overlay-Networks, dass die Browser, wenn du ein Socks-Proxy angibst, zwar den eigentlichen Request an den Webserver über dieses Netz abgeben, die DNS-Abfrage aber weiterhin rausgeht. Das heißt, der Bedarfträger auf der Leitung sieht...
Weil das nicht TCP ist.
Du fragst nach www.aidspatientenforum.de und dann sieht er zwar nicht, dass du die Seite www.aidspatientenforum.de abgerufen hast, aber dein Rechner hat zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt nach dieser Maschinenadresse für diesen Namen gefragt. Das lässt ja doch wieder Rückschlüsse zu. Deswegen, auch wie der Privoxy sehr hilfreich ist, der übernimmt das für einen. Der kann das über das Socks-Netzwerk tun.
Verstehe.
Aber es ist nicht ganz einfach aufzusetzen. Es ist schon immer noch so, dass es eine gewisse Kenntnis braucht, an wie funktioniert meine Maschine, wie funktioniert Netzwerkkommunikation mit meinem Betriebssystem, wie funktioniert mein Webbrowser, wie funktionieren andere Dienste, um nicht versehentlich Informationen nach draußen zu geben. Die arbeiten natürlich auch dran, im Tor-Projekt das benutzerfreundlicher zu machen, das Kernteam an Programmierern ist. Und auch Dritte, wir sind da ja auch beteiligt. Aber letztlich ist es immer noch so, dass es jetzt eher eine Domäne ist von Leuten, die sich mit ihrem Rechner intensiv auseinandersetzen. Nicht nur Leute wie du und ich, aber schon auch Leute mit einem gewissen technischen Grundverständnis.
Ja, das hat man ja auch auf dem Kongress gesehen. Da gab es ja, ich glaube, vor zwei Jahren einen sehr schönen Vortrag von Steve Murdoch, der was sehr Schönes gemacht hat, der sich irgendwie, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, weißt du, wie er es gemacht hat? Er hat selber einen Exit-Note betrieben. Also was er getan hat, ist, dass er Rechner beobachtet hat, die über Tor kommuniziert haben. Und er hat sich dann die Datenpakete angeschaut und korrigiere mich, wenn ich jetzt was Falsches sage, das ist jetzt so ein bisschen die Zusammenfassung aus dem Kopf, hat sich die Zeitabweichungen angeschaut, die diese Datenströme von den Rechnern zum Besten gegeben haben. Das heißt, eigentlich sollten sie ja anonym sein, aber er hat es dann geschafft, über diese Zeitinformation eine Lokalisierung dieser Rechner auf dem Planeten vorzunehmen.
Genau, und das Konzept war, dass er geguckt hat, wie ist die Abweichung der Uhr. Wenn er ein Datenpaket bekommt, hat er einen Zeitstempel, hat das zurückgerechnet und geguckt, wie ist die Abweichung der Uhrzeit des Rechners.
Über den Tagesverlauf.
Und hat darüber hinaus zurückgerechnet, wie ist wohl die Raumtemperatur, weil dieser Quarz, der da drin ist, der die Uhr treibt, offensichtlich Temperaturschwankungen unterliegt. Und dann hat dieser Temperaturschwankungen die Präzision der Uhrzeit abweicht.
Das ist so großartig.
Damit kann er herausfinden, ist es da gerade hell, ist es da gerade Sommer.
Das heißt, man muss sich das so vorstellen, die Elektronik atmet anders nachts, als es tagsüber tut. Und sogar so etwas Hochirres, wie ein Quarz, der schwingt und dann eine Uhr antreibt, und das ist ja eine Eigenschaft jedes Rechners, zeigt einfach ein unterschiedliches Verhalten, ob es tagsüber ist oder ob es nachts ist. Und natürlich, weil man ja auch sehen kann, wann es Tag wird und wann es Nacht wird, weiß man dann schon mal ziemlich ganz genau den Längengrad. Und über die Länge des Tages und der Nacht könnte man eigentlich auch schon mal Rückschlüsse über den Breitengrad führen.
Vermutlich.
Weil Sommer, lange Tage, Winter, dann weiß man schon mal, ob er im Norden oder im Süden ist. Und ich glaube, er hat relativ präzise Ortungen vorgenommen.
Er hat auch interessanterweise jedem Rechner sozusagen sein Atmungsmuster festgeschrieben. Also wenn wir bei diesem Vergleich bleiben, wäre es, er hat rausgefunden über Telefonate mit Menschen anhand deren Atmung, ob es da gerade hell ist und ob es da gerade Sommer ist. Und er hat sich dieses charakteristische Abweichungsmuster notiert, sodass er diesen Rechner wiederfindet, wenn er auf der anderen Seite des Erdbeils, wenn du mit deinem Notebook in Tokio, dass du da vier Wochen im Büro hattest, um irgendwie Internet zu klicken, mitnimmst, weil du jetzt vier Wochen in San Francisco bist, dann weiß er, dass du deinen Rechner mitgenommen hast. Das ist schon ganz schön Voodoo-Magic.
Tracking at its best, das fand ich echt beeindruckend. Aber das zeigt, dass auch die beste Anonymisierung ihre Grenzen hat. Es gibt so viele Dinge, wodurch man, wenn man digital kommuniziert, seine Identität kommunizieren kann, bis hin zu den Atmungseigenschaften des eigenen Rechners, eines kleinen Chips, der eigentlich nichts anderes macht, als zu schwingen. Und schon signalisiert man seine Identität. Gibt es da irgendwelche Bestrebungen, die Tor-Software dahin gehen zu verbessern, um so eine Sache vielleicht auch noch auszugleichen?
Puh, da fragst du mich was. Es ist ja auch immer so, dass das akademische Überlegungen sind, dass die nur unter bestimmten Rahmenbedingungen funktionieren, dass auch nicht absehbar ist, wie sich das verändert, wenn das Netzwerk wächst. Das ist eine der schwierigsten Eigenschaften überhaupt, die Wachstumsrate zu bestimmen und zu gucken, wie öffnet man das Netz, wie skaliert das, wenn es größer wird. Und welche Bedrohungsszenarien sind wannfahrbar? Ich meine, diese Attacke, die kann ich nicht wirklich bewerten, inwiefern das möglich ist, das flächendeckend einzusetzen. Die Frage ist halt immer Anonymität gegenüber wem auch. Wenn du einen Überwacher hast, der beide Enden der Kommunikation beobachten kann, kannst du ohnehin mehr oder weniger deutlich feststellen, dass da ein Kommunikationsvorgang ist, weil du anhand von Korrelationsanalysen siehst, jemand fragt blödes Beispiel www.cccde nach und www.cccde gibt diese Seite raus. Wenn du das komplette Netz überwachen kannst, dann siehst du halt diesen Vorgang und dann kann dir auch gerne eine Sekunde doch Anonymisierung ausletztwerk laufen, aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit, das ist derjenige...
Moment, wir sind wieder bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, während das im Prinzip umgeht. Wenn man einfach alles mal speichert, dann kann man auch nachträglich gucken. Und vor allem, man hat auch alle Zeit der Welt. Also man kann es vielleicht nicht in Echtzeit mitverfolgen, aber wenn man nachträglich da mal nachschauen will, kann man eigentlich alles Mögliche da rausrechnen. Und es ist noch nicht mal... Ich weiß gar nicht, ob unsere Vorstellungskraft ausreicht für das, was da alles möglich ist.
Ich will mir das auch gar nicht vorstellen, da kriege ich schlechte Laune von.
Ja, genau, das wollen wir ja nicht. Unsere Laune hält sich noch ganz gut, weil es noch Schokokekse und Klubmater gibt.
Die Frage ist, wie weit ist das Know-how vorhanden, um genau so etwas rauszurechnen? Ich kann mich noch erinnern, so mit 19 oder so hat mir Andreas mal erklärt, wie Radar funktioniert und wie man die Radarauflösung verändern kann. Also letztlich EVEX, das Flugraumüberwachungssystem der NATO, was eine umgebaute Boeing ist, auf der eine große Antenne ist. Ich hoffe, ihr habt mir das damals gut gemerkt. Die Länge der Radarantenne entspricht der Flugstrecke, weil man die Zeitdifferenz rausrechnet. Das heißt, du fliegst einmal von Flensburg nach Garmisch-Partenkirchen und zurück. Und dann ist die Länge der Radarantenne die Bundesrepublik, weil du den Zeitunterschied rausrechnest. Du hast ja immer momentane Snapshots mit einem Zeitstempel, und dann rechnest du dir den Zeitunterschied da raus. Und dafür gibt es wohl DSPs und fertigen Code. Andreas hat mir das damals erklärt, wie funktioniert Radar, wie funktioniert AVEX, was ist der Texas Instruments DSP, auf dem die Amerikaner das implementiert haben, mit welcher Software, was sind da die Probleme. Und das ist halt digitale Signalverarbeitung. Das lernt jeder an der Uni. Das ist kein Voodoo-Magic, das ist da. Und ich nehme an, mit Vorratsdaten kann man entsprechend verfahren, wenn man einen entsprechend optimierten Code verschreibt.
Wenn es erstmal da ist.
Und dann kann man halt diese Sachen auch handhaben. Und immer dieses Verlassen darauf, dass es nicht funktionieren wird. Die Argumentation ja, das Recht würde nun einen ungeheuer weitreichenden Eingriff ermöglichen, aber das wird ja nicht passieren, weil die technische Kapazität bei Vyp nicht ausreicht, um diese Datenmengen zu verarbeiten. Die Überwacher werden daran ersticken, ist immer so das Argument. Sonst werten sie einfach nicht, Computer werden dauernd billiger.
Und Festplatten werden vor allem dauernd billiger.
Und Metadaten sind halt nicht so viel. Wir hatten mal anhand der veröffentlichten Gesprächsminutenzahlen in den Telefonnetzen überlegt, was es kosten würde, die gesamte Telekommunikation eines Landes zu speichern. Wenn man die vorher durch einen GSM-Codec schickt, dann konnte man das fünf Jahre her. Für 100 Millionen Mark war das glaube ich damals, einfach die gesamte Kommunikation der Bundesrepublik auf Platte speichern. Und wenn man es auf Tape schreibt, ist es noch viel billiger. Das reicht aber, wenn man die Metadaten hat. Dann klickt man auf Tim Pritlove und dann muss der Bandroboter mal irgendwie eine Nacht lang Bänder schieben. Mein Gott, dafür ist er da. Und sofern solche Prozesse automatisierbar sind, und das sind sie, erlaubt es halt deutliche Kontrolle. Und Metadatenanalyse, da sind wir wieder bei Xanalys Watson. Das Sample-File, was es damals gab, war, wie finde ich Befehlsketten in Telefonverbindungsdaten. Das ist zehn Jahre her. Da wirft man halt alle Verbindungsdaten rein. Und dann fällt ein bunter Graph raus, der zeigt, wer hat das Kommando gegeben an Stellvertreter 1 und 2, wen haben die wann angerufen, wie lang war der Delay, haben die Leute untereinander miteinander telefoniert oder gab es da irgendwie klare Hierarchien.
Und alle sind glücklich, weil man ja endlich was an der Hand hat gegen die organisierte Kriminalität. Und jetzt werden irgendwie die ganzen Autos, die in den Osten verschoben werden und so weiter, die kriegen wir jetzt alle. Aber dass natürlich auch eine politische Widerstandsgruppe, Umweltaktivisten oder irgendwie auch der Chaos Computer Club letzten Endes genauso ein Profil aufwerfen in solchen Verbindungsdaten.
Journalisten.
Journalisten, Rechtsanwälte, was auch immer.
Zielsorger, Ärzte.
Ja, alle diese Leute. Wird das jetzt alles bald sichtbar sein? Und was nicht sofort sichtbar ist, das ist dann halt irgendwie ein halbes Jahr später, wenn die Software dann fertig gehackt ist, alles sichtbar. Und das ist echt bedrohlich. Und deswegen ist der Kampf gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung auch noch lange nicht vorbei. Denn dem muss einfach ein Riegel vorgeschoben werden. So geht es nicht. Ich meine, wir haben alle so ein bisschen immer die Hoffnung mit dem verfassungsgebenden Organ, schützenden Organ, Entschuldigung, also nicht dem Verfassungsgericht in Deutschland. Das ist aber natürlich in den anderen Ländern nicht unbedingt so. Das Schlimme ist ja immer, ich habe jetzt hier noch so meine letzte Notiz, irgendwie so, was so droht. England, USA und China. Ich meine, das ist so ein bisschen natürlich der bittere Blick nach vorne. Also wenn man sich anschaut, wie andere Länder mit dieser Frage umgehen, wo es irgendwie gar keine nennenswerte Opposition gibt, wo Gesetzgebungen schon in Kraft sind, bzw. Gesetzgebungen eben, selbst wenn sie in Kraft sind, nicht beachtet werden. Ja, dann kann einem schon so ein bisschen übel werden.
Insofern, das können wir auch noch mal festhalten bei allen, was man gegen diesen Staat sagt. Ich glaube schon, dass das Land und seine Bürger aus den zwei totalitären Regimen gelernt haben. Nicht viel, aber so ein bisschen.
Die Bundesrepublik Deutschland, machst du.
In ihrer jetzigen Form und Verfasstheit. Das aber, das technische Instrumentarium, was da geschaffen wird, zum Teil auch mit Verweis auf eine supranationale Entität, nämlich die Europäische Union oder im Zweifel die GE8 oder die OECD oder wer auch immer gerade Dinge vorschreibt oder die in Interpol, der nach den Vereinten Nationen zweitgrößten internationalen Entität, nämlich dem Zusammenschluss der Kriminalpolizei-Organisationen der Länder dieser Erde, was ja auch gut gemeint ist. Das sind ja Dinge, die deren Arbeit erleichtern und das kann man zunächst einmal so hinnehmen, dass es in deren Interesse sein muss, da Veränderungen herbeizuführen. Dass das aber zeitgleich nationale Schutzräume aushebelt und nationale Gesetzgebung unterwandert, das kann nicht sein. Und dann ist halt die Frage, muss man vor das Bundesverfassungsgericht ziehen und solange Eins und solange Zwei in Frage stellen. Also Gesetzgebung, die sagt, europäische Gesetzgebung, sehr vereinfacht gesprochen, europäisches Gesetzgebung ist okay, solange der im Grundgesetz gesicherte Schutz vorhanden bleibt. Und wenn das nicht mehr der Fall ist, dann nun. Aber es ist halt ein sehr schwieriger Prozess, ein zeitaufwendiger Prozess. Und ein Prozess, der den Gesetzgeber fordert und der hört gerade nicht mehr zu, ist taub und blind, offensichtlich überfordert und funktioniert nicht mehr. Und da kenne ich auch keinen Ausweg. Ein möglicher Schritt wäre sicherlich, die Zahl der Legislaturperioden zu begrenzen. Möglicherweise ist das auch so ein bisschen zu entzerren, auf fünf Jahre, nicht auf vier, weil im ersten Jahr sind sie dabei, sich einzugewöhnen. Im fünften Jahr, also jetzt im vierten, machen sie Wahlkampf und tun nichts mehr. Das heißt, die Zeitspanne, in der Arbeit passiert, ist relativ gering. Dann, wenn die Zahl der Legislaturperioden nicht begrenzt ist, ist es schon so, dass da Berufspolitiker hinkommen, die das halt machen, weil sie Politik machen, weil das ihr Beruf ist, nicht Leute, die das machen, weil sie sich ihres Themas annehmen wollen. Und dann auch die Frage nach der Wahl. Solange man Politik nur betreiben kann im Rahmen der Fraktionsdisziplin, wenn man sonst nie wieder auf die Liste kommt, dann braucht es halt mehr Direktkandidaten, wenn man sich Herrn Ströbele anguckt. Auch bis vor allem schwieriger Zeitgenosse, sicherlich. Aber der hat den großen, großen Vorteil, der ist Direktkandidat des Bezirks Berlin Friedrichshain und Kreuzberg. Und in seinem Wahlkreis direkt gewählt heißt, dem ist es egal, ob wir ihn auf eine Liste stellen oder nicht. Der kann einfach die Hand heben und sagen, ich bin dagegen. Tut er ja auch.
Und da ist er aber auch wirklich einer von wenigen.
Allein auf weiter Flur.
Bei den meisten Parlamentariern hat man eher das Gefühl, dass sie auch eigentlich gar nicht wissen, was sie da tun. Bei dem Internet ist es wirklich ganz schlimm. Also es ist gut, dass die Minister nicht wissen, was Browser sind, und dass sich der Innenminister das Internet ausdrucken lässt. Da hat man sich schon fast dran gewöhnt. Aber auch diese ganze Parlamentarier-Schar ist einfach auch vollkommen überfordert. Ja, da fällt mir nur zu ein, dass ich in meiner mittlerweile sehr langen Liste von künftigen Themen auch noch mal eine Vorschlagsliste zur Einführung in Politik vorsehe, wo man den Einfluss nehmen kann. Weil das Fass mache ich jetzt hier nicht mehr auf. Denn ich wollte mich hier konzentrieren mit dir auf Anonymisierung, den Bedarf dafür und die Mittel, die zur Verfügung stehen. Und ich denke, das haben wir jetzt auch ganz gut gemacht.
Zumindest den Ansatz nicht, die technischen Details kann man dann beliebig tief ausführen. Aber das soll nicht Gegenstand der Radiosendung, sondern unter anderem des Kongresses sein. Roger Dingel, dein wird dieses Jahr glücklicherweise wieder anwesend sein.
Ah ja, also derjenige, der Trogenspiemen hat, der Autor, genau, wird auf dem 24. Chaos-Communication-Kongress da sein. Auch ein Ausblick auf den Kongress ist im Übrigen geplant bei Chaosradio Express. Aber ich sollte lieber das Maul halten, weil immer, wenn man anfängt, irgendwelche Themen anzukündigen, dann fallen sie wieder aus irgendwelchen bekloppten Gründen aus. Also halten wir jetzt das Maul. Aber wir halten unsere Klappe nicht und gehen auch weiterhin vor gegen die allgemein verbreitete Dummheit, wenn es um digitale Kommunikation geht. Und ich sage Dankeschön, Andreas. Und ja, www.ccc.de Anonymizer, dort findet ihr das Angebot des Clubs. Aber es gibt auch noch viele andere, wenn ihr euch einbringen wollt. Dann gibt es da alle Möglichkeiten. Schaut durch die Links der Sendung. Ansonsten Feedback zur Sendung, wie immer, chaosradio.ccc.de oder ihr kommentiert eine der Einträge in unserem Blog, was es jetzt auch gibt, unter blog.chaosradio.ccc.de, um die Ressourcen mal komplett abzufeiern. Es gibt natürlich auch noch das Wiki, wo sich immer sehr viele schöne Drittinformationen ganz automatisch einfinden. Und ja, das war es soweit. Ich sage Tschüss. Da ich spiele mir noch die tolle Musik zum Ausklang, damit wir hier auch alle in der richtigen Stimmung bleiben. Ja, bis bald.
Vorratsdatenspeicherung, Swift-Datenübermittlung, Terrorismusbekämpfungsgesetz, präventive Telekommunikations-
Wir haben die Fibotrophie des Staates maurisch genug erlebt. Wir hatten nun bei uns in Deutschland den mit falschem Pathos verklehmten und in primitiven Desch-Machs-Esanthismus von pommelrealisierend totalitären Staat und den im Hintergrund haben wir in das Grundgesetz erneut gelegt, das Bekenntnis zu Menschenrecht und Menschenwirbel. Und das ist in diesem Zusammenhang, an dieser Stelle, zu dieser Zeit keine sentimentale Maske.
Das Grundgesetz Recht sichert Freiheit. Man kann Freiheit nicht sichern, indem man Recht abbaut. Recht sichert Freiheit. Staat ist nicht der Staat, bei dem gezwickte Mittel heiligt. Staat ist der Staat der inneren Gewissheit. Das heißt der Gewissheit darüber, dass die Menschen und die Bürgerrechte und deren Beachtung noch immer die besten Garanten der inneren Sicherheit sind. Recht sichert Freiheit.
Sie müssen sich darüber klar werden, dass sie nicht an den Grundlagen unserer Demokratie herumdoktern können, wie es ihnen gerade beliebt.
So was gibt es, so was gibt es. Wir wollen die Warnung weiter perfektionieren. Indem wir Verdachtsurapie alle kontrollieren. Wir wollen die Warnung weiter perfektionieren.
Datenabgleich bei Leistungsentfängern, Geldwäschebekämpfungsgesetz, großer Lauschabgriff. Massen-GTES, schweiziger Informationssystem.
Versteht der Bürger sowieso nicht. Auf Wiedersehen!